[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right cut dough buff
hey what's up guys i hope you like that
commercial of me [ __ ] sweating so
this is something i'm very excited about
marty's really excited about it we are
officially sponsored by on it and this
is our very first ad read and i know a
lot of you a lot of you that watch
podcast already know what's going on
you're
actually right now going what the [ __ ]
you got on it i know but for those of
you that don't know what on it is this
is
a fitness lifestyle everything brand so
as you can see this kettlebell right
here this giant iron man kettlebell this
is from on it they make weights
this is a brain focus supplement this is
whey protein they have everything it's a
fitness brand slash supplements and a
lot of you are at home going
why is this fat guy talking about
fitness trying to sell me fitness [ __ ]
guys i used to do weight lifting
competitions i used to be in shape i
just got [ __ ] fat but i'm saying this
right now guys marty and i if you've
been here for the first episode
the fitness challenge i want to do a
pull-up by what was it episode 52
guys i'm what is it it's july about to
be august by the end of the year i'm
trying to fit into an xl shirt i wear a
3xl shirt man i have never worn a 3xl in
my life
so this is motivation i have the gym
here i have all the audit stuff i have
the supplements i have the weights
there's no excuse anymore hold me to it
guys by the end of the year i'm going to
be
not so fat and more importantly guys i
will be a lot healthier because
in the end all this yeah you look cool
you're above but are you healthy
that's really the main thing for me i'm
happy i'm just not [ __ ] healthy so i
need to get on it guys
i have natural advertisement i'm going
to get on it guys
go to www.onit.com that's onnit.com use
codeola at checkout
[Music]
what is up what's up guys i am thomas
dopeziola whatever you want to call me
welcome back to the dope as usual
podcast
we're here to talk about life problems
drugs accomplishments and everything in
between and i am saying
the intro marty because i forgot we have
a pre-roll ad and that killed that first
30 seconds
so i can say drugs you say the word
drugs even though it says drug store
on cvs but for some reason drugs gets us
demonetized
so uh guys let's get this episode
started how are you doing
solo episode we are back i am awake
even though it is 12 30 at night
and you just did a full [ __ ] workout
i did just do a full workout uh oh yeah
the on it i know it's the same shirt
i know the guy that makes these shirts i
promise you that this is a different
shirt
i was sweating it up in the same shirt i
promise this is a different shirt
but you remember in space jam where he's
like oh
you got to go back to my house michael
jordan's telling the tunes go back to my
house
get my shorts shorts yeah and they're
like uh
i watched them after every game yeah you
said it's warm every day since middle
school or some [ __ ] yeah i warm out
every game
i watched them after every i promise
that's how i feel about the shirt i
promised i got a different shirt all
right
speaking of space jam
the new space jam lebron i have a lot of
faith in him because i saw other
few movies with him and he was not a bad
actor he was actually kind of funny
my opinion on this new space fan was
garbage ah
you had to give that opportunity like
that because i'm like i was so ready for
it
but when i watched it i mean i know when
a movie's bad when i do this
and rosie's doing this to me you're like
yo are we turning this [ __ ] off right
now
i was seven minutes in going
i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here this
free movie i'm watching on
amazon prime i might not want to watch
it damn it's a amazon prime freebie
i think or hbo max i can't remember but
it's in theaters but if you have a
certain thing
anyway i watched it and i'm not going to
spoil let me spoil it you know what the
[ __ ] happens
uh first off they should've got danny
devito again to play the bad guy
would have made me stay the whole time
um
i got halfway through the move i'm not
going to ruin it for you guys i got
halfway through the moving going this is
[ __ ] dog [ __ ]
this is stupid as [ __ ] and then it got
to the uh
the basketball playoff game and it was a
little better
still still kind of whacked me i just i
don't i'm biased bro the number the
first one is just
well they play they put lebron as a
cartoon you're saying right so that
already okay so when he got sucked into
tune world guys i'm not spoiling
anything
he stayed cartoon michael jordan got
sucked into the golf course with
newman and bill bill murray he was a
human and that's why they were like
whoa a human michael jordan
tweety bird and [ __ ] that's gotta be
coveted they gotta be like we couldn't
kill lebron
but he was still a human in the first
part and the second probably had the
third five days
i don't know but i was very let's just
call it that i know
i'm biased because i love the 90s
version but this [ __ ]
like the new spider-man that i was
telling you about you told me it's
amazing the one where he had the jordans
on and [ __ ]
he showed me it's amazing amazing you're
the third person to tell me that i'm
[ __ ] slipping not watching it
i need to watch it i'm a little
disappointed this didn't have that same
kind of effect because
i was waiting nerd i was waiting man
lebron james is the michael jordan now
and they had bill murray out there in
the first one they had [ __ ] larry
bird out there
with the slacks on on the golf course it
was funny they had
comedians real comedians but this one
just go watch it if you want to watch it
uh or first watch
if you have kids out there or if you're
too young and you haven't watched the
old space jam
watch the old one first then watch the
new one
go ahead and watch every movie from 96
first what else came in 96 the mask
you don't want me to even pull it up
because 96
was i kind of do want you to pull are
you talking about it
i'm going to be like oh okay what the
[ __ ] we'll stop i get you i got you i
get you so
i know happy gilmore probably came out
the mass probably came out
um
i don't know i don't know oh also before
two fear came out in 96
matilda came out in 96
what all of these came out in 96.
i i was looking at the music what yeah
the music is probably hard 96 and seven
is
like great years of all time for music
and movies um
real quick before we get into this guys
this podcast i am 100 me
marty says hour and a half we have to
hour and a half this
because last time we said hour and a
half turned into three it's been a crazy
ass week we're out of such a crazy week
real quick before we get started
marty what have you been doing for the
past two days uh
i've been talking on sat in a situation
that involved an nda so i am oh so
it is nda yeah for sure because when you
brought this [ __ ] up no no it's all
right it's a
pilot presentation it's real interesting
the whole situation and
in filming something with the intention
of it being pitched out to like netflix
and hulu but
uh yeah i've been on set the past two
days in this [ __ ] 150 degree sun out
here in the valley but it was amazing
and uh bts yeah we'll be able to talk
about it and
you know hopefully a few months and
you'll be able to see this [ __ ] on a
major [ __ ]
that'd be awesome also one more thing um
i gotta start talking to the camera
i keep forgetting and i have a full
conversation with marty and i'm not
looking at any camera
that's fine this camera is getting like
when you're keeping it forgetting though
forgetting it looks like you got a blind
guy
what's up man how you doing got the
wandering looking this way yeah
so when i watch him back i'm like yo did
i do it again
so i'll stay right here all right um you
should just move my seat
yo we should just move your seat that's
not even a bad idea
can you why do you have danny devito's
instagram i was gonna ask you because
you saw
it was him though that rosie showed me
with pictures of his feet twitter
uh dannyville on twitter does this thing
called like the troll foot he just takes
a picture of his foot
in a different cool background all the
time rosie's been following
it she's done it a few times because we
love danny devito but recently look what
danny devito posted popping up on the
screen
[ __ ] insane that's marty's poster
that's marty's artwork with danny
devito's foot
i thought listen this one up on madison
square garden
and i thought that was legendary this is
cool legendary because danny devito's in
it
wow so cool well part of him the cool
part
i wonder oh this is new york city okay
yeah that's yeah that's marty's artwork
how awesome
it's epic man yeah that went out as soon
as the pandemic started so like
i had my graphics for the first time i
didn't even know what was gonna happen
on all of the billboards across madison
square garden and nobody was
in new york oh that's right nobody saw
it
i got my art management square oh the
world's closed and nobody saw it for
a couple bums maybe uh-huh that weren't
good yeah the dude from uh
you know who the crowmags are the crow
mags and i have no idea
they're you know like a rock band from
out of new york city or whatever
but um the main dude from the crow mags
yeah american hardcore punk band
oh nice uh he went on rogan this dude
had an amazing
podcast on rogan and he took a video
and sent it to rogan look of it yeah of
it so that's how i even knew about it
cool
then roger posted that that's epic um
can you go back to my notes real quick
yeah guys like i said we're trying to
keep this an hour and a half
we're really really really trying and as
you can see
the honors sponsorship was [ __ ] major
thank you guys so much for making that
happen marty and i have been working on
that for i don't know once
that's a huge major milestone and the
thing about on it
on it's worked with all the biggest
podcasts but
they will stay with you what i love
about anna is that like
there's shows that i started working on
in 2013 that
they still sponsor damn they will lock
in with you
forever if they fall in line with your
show and your fans
which i really can appreciate that all
the podcasts i grew up listening to they
did that with they're the
i would say the biggest like
outreach of podcast ad partner to the
biggest podcast out there
the fact that rogan owns isn't like part
of the company is
probably part of it yeah but it was
crazy to watch it from one supplement
for anybody that doesn't know the alpha
brain it started with that
and now on it yeah it grew from that one
supplement
to like the biggest fitness and you know
company
one of the biggest companies in the
world they got a whole campus
down in austin where you walk in they
got to shop they got with all their
apparel
all their supplements they got the shake
booth where you go get your nice
smoothie made and then
the whole campus is done up and art like
how we have the set
it's like that but in this badass
fine art that is just their style though
music right yeah yeah so they got
multiple gyms in there they got multiple
sets they got
professional athletes professional
military people in there
everything they got the jiu jitsu
section they got the muay thai they got
the 10th planet
they got so much [ __ ] going down on this
when he gave me the tour of the campus i
was like
it's incredible that this happened so
when you think about within 10 years
from
one supplement they were able to and
their web design like i've been
following them handling everything
forever
very top-notch man i've like they're
been ahead of the game
across from a branding and like design
visual perspective since day one
they had these sick ass lucid dreaming
sites that's the idea behind alpha brain
is that
it'll it'll slip you into lucid dreaming
i couldn't do it no more ever since it's
so weird i only had lucid dream my whole
life until i started dating rosie
and the right when i started sleeping
next to another person i just went away
i used to be able to be hyped to go to
sleep as a kid and go
all right what am i doing tonight all
right cool go i fall asleep and
start off in what i was thinking damn
because you don't have crazy dreams i
used to be able to control
everything and know when it was fake and
and when it was real
so i knew i could do whatever i wanted
in my dreams i just remember in the hulk
remember the hulk with edward norton was
running through like the grand canyon
just
jumping miles that's what i used to do
through cities in my dreams
i would love that it's so fun bro like
regret just grabbing the ground
throwing yourself a mile it's mm-hmm
it's like when spider-man does the
yeah leaps over a building that's what
it is so fun
but yeah alpha brain anyway yeah we're
on that's the brain
thanks mom acid brain for real mom [ __ ]
geez how how long are we right now i
really want to smoke
11. [ __ ] great yeah yeah um
here we go guys i'm going to try a
different formula today
usually we talk about a bunch of stuff
get into some stories
let me start you off right with a story
right at the beginning let's hit it hard
i'm going to try my best
to talk to the camera and not marty all
right marty i'm going to try my best all
right guys
introducing uh story time in the i mean
we always do story time in the podcast
but
here's a little intro the reason i
brought this one up is because
i know seven in the morning i was going
to sleep two nights ago because i edited
all night and i was doing a bunch of
[ __ ]
i can't sleep so i have a
if you follow the other channel i bought
us amg
in september last year one of the cars
i've always wanted my whole life i
[ __ ] got it right
and i got the amg c63 which is baller
it's a baller car
and then this girl in my apartment
building moved in
and she has the amg gt and you know what
this is every time you see
like a uh see i don't know the fine
details of these benzes but you get all
[ __ ] frustrated i only knew
up to last year when i started building
my dream car on google on major cities i
went
i'm gonna get it no matter what i have
to do i have to work as hard as possible
i work till seven in the [ __ ] morning
i'm getting it
and when i got i'm like yeah what the
[ __ ] is that car
and i'm like what is that they go oh
that's a little too much right now
oh okay [ __ ] you and then i went
what a month ago and i was gonna go by
i'm like [ __ ] it i'm gonna go buy it
i'm gonna trade this car in and get it
and then they're like hey
uh [ __ ] you your credit money
[ __ ] you the last car you bought was a
honda we're not
supplying you 180 000 car and even
though that's way too much [ __ ] money
for me to be
i get it i'm an [ __ ] but i really
wanted the car so the reason i bring
this all up because in the seven in the
morning the other night i went
i don't want that car [ __ ] that car i
want to get a house first
even though the house i wanted to take
years
i said you know what i'm gonna wrap and
put rims on my [ __ ] 2020 the amg is
still sick
i love my car but every time i walk out
and see that girl and i can see your car
my i love your car
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying it's like
that little
the house is the move though um the
house is coming no matter what but yeah
the house i want because it's la
it's four million dollars it's a lot of
money man yeah
but the down payment's 800 pounds get it
i'll [ __ ] make it work somehow
but man [ __ ] by the way i'm trying i'm
trying by the way
marty just bought a house
guys come on jesus christ
holy [ __ ] you bought a house it's been
two
three years in the in the aggressively
looking
his wife's a realtor yeah she's on it
this pandemic market was uh
insane this would be the last [ __ ]
session about this hopefully
i knew like anybody out there thinking
about getting a house like
sometimes in this market like this you
have to get
a situation where you have we had to go
knock on doors
like that crazy literally houses that
were on the market then came off the
market
you're thinking about still selling your
house because we can make this really
easy yeah like
that's what's wild would you go through
neighborhoods
man yeah i mean [ __ ] but marty brings us
really cute as a little daughter
yeah hi we're thinking about buying a
house would you be selling your house
that they got it
that's what it talked man you know what
you know what to do
yeah so i'm gonna bring you the little
one
yeah but yeah the house that we ended up
getting this looks like a good situation
so the house you see well you showed me
it yeah we went
down payment today but yeah you jumped
down today
[Music]
huge so it's just such we've been like
in limbo
and like uh what's the word where you're
between heaven and hell like
purgatory purgatory favorite beats
please we like we need to move on in
life we need to get past this
it's and it's just we've been at such a
[ __ ] stance though putting
so many times i talk to you yeah i'm
gonna look at a new house and then i'm
gonna come back and i gotta edit every
goddamn house that we wanna get 40
offers on it and goes for
[ __ ] 100 grand more than we got in
the market for how epic though man you
got your house
yeah it's right next to my office
because my office has been fire it's a
hassle to get to but i love it
and my lives in like far orange county
it is
bomb it's right off the freeway isis
[ __ ] in his city i won't say what city
but
damn yeah irvine oh irvine's
nice i didn't want to put it up there
guys the irvine's get
damn near the nicest like suburban small
city in america i'm gonna throw that out
there
so marty yeah how long did it take you
took you 10 years
we were plotting on this since we first
got you moved and i'm saying like oh it
took you forever
we moved here exactly eight years ago
you got it yeah like to the day
damn near like the memories are popping
up on my facebook of us driving out here
and [ __ ] that first month wow
yeah we had a three three-month airbnb
that we were splitting the rant with
with my boy i did music with
and he ended up dipping out early and
kind of [ __ ] you
i mean it worked it worked out we got so
lucky
yeah but that was the first thing yeah
[ __ ] yeah suck a car
that's huge that was my whole goal my
that was
about my life goal up until this point
is to be able to buy a house out here
and be able to not even that
we won't go into detail that's a nice
ass house yeah i mean it will be it's
not
a full remodel you put that house in
buffalo you go yeah i got the nicest
house in the box
yeah i mean that's but i know pick it up
put it here go now i live in
by the beach yeah yeah you're doing a
good job man like you finally did it
everything's paying off finally all this
hard ass work yeah and like
you know i'm 34 so i feel old as [ __ ]
but in the grand scheme of things we're
still pretty young to be buying like a
million dollar house out here basically
so
damn i'm over here just going around all
these things like yeah [ __ ] it million
dollar house
like yo that's yeah [ __ ] awesome yeah
yeah but that's just what it costs i
know that's not some [ __ ] mansion
that's a regular house
there's so many variables in this [ __ ]
but it's one of those things in life
where
can like so many things have to come
together your credit you have to have
enough
money you have all these alignment
everything has to come together but then
you're not just throwing your [ __ ]
money away every month
yeah towards nothing or to rent somebody
else's mortgage like the key
is buying the property especially if
you're in some shitty little city that
is the only way i've seen people legally
make it happen
buy a property and a double and rent out
the other half of it
and save and save and then flip and then
get another one get a three unit
yes key that can that's realistic for
anybody
so it works my grandma and grandpa came
here
broke mexicans another ball and
i would tell you that my dad's parents
are balling home yeah yeah
okay they don't act like it i was broken
hungry my whole life
oh i know but they were riches yeah
mm-hmm
i had a similar situation oh yeah oh
yeah we'll get into it
that's all right but i remember yeah
[ __ ] my [ __ ] my family invented screen
printing
do you know that justin sorry my friend
justin's here too
this was family invented this screen
printing
they're bawling on the east coast yeah
yeah they did all the shirts for the
[ __ ]
super super bowls the mlp's the michael
jordan era
all the live nation pink floyd garth
brooks
doors any drake like still to this day
like yeah they they don't like hands-on
anymore as much because they're
balling yeah well they got bought out by
gildan oh
[ __ ] really so they just got bought out
too by some
i think it was a.s color it's color
bottom it was probably like maybe 10
years ago but they they still do they
still do it just on a smaller
they don't have giant factories and
[ __ ] or you know across seas and [ __ ]
whenever i think of people owning
factories and [ __ ] i go back to jumanji
and allen parish shoe factory yeah
like where's david alan greer when you
need his ass yeah i
love that movie side note about that
though i didn't reconnect with
that side of my family until adulthood
yeah you know that's why i marched
same situation like my family would talk
to that part of the family
they got mad yeah so so
marty's got a house guys feels it it
doesn't feel real yet i'm not excited
until you move in and it's done in the
first night and you'll
enjoy your backyard yeah then you'd like
now what yeah i don't ever feel happy
until i'm done unpacking yeah because
i'm i've moved for how many years
i am packed the start of the month i
move mm-hmm packed up 100 leave out some
clothes and i'm done i sit on the couch
at my bed and everything's put away
i'll [ __ ] use paper plates i'm done
because i used to do so many moves where
i walk in like oh yeah so just
help us pack them i hate packing
people's underwear drawers and [ __ ]
i can't stand lazy [ __ ] i get
that you're paying us but
you just pay me 1500 extra to pack your
stuff
that's crazy i didn't even know that was
a thing no i've packed people's
full toothbrushes this i wouldn't have
done something taking their
laundry out of their [ __ ] laundry
like machine washing machines
and taking it out of the dryer like what
about this oh yeah am i closing the
dryer
draining the water out taking the
[ __ ] washing machine
that's not a moving service that's like
that's what i used to
actually [ __ ] time so i really can't
stand people aren't packed and ready to
go yeah
so when i move i'm ready to go i pack
move and i'm packing one day i do not
wait
everything is packed rosie's putting
pictures up as i'm moving [ __ ] in mm-hmm
[ __ ] that and i have four moving
companies in my family
yeah you're not just knowing i know what
i'm doing probably have kids hiring them
now they
compound all their [ __ ] [ __ ] well
next time you move you want help i'll
call my cousin adrian he just owns a
moving company
he'll come down here i'll smoke a bunch
of weed with him and then do the [ __ ]
move it's really cool yeah professional
[ __ ] they're like five-star rated on
everything they're bomb
because we've been doing our whole lives
we know exactly what we're sick they
come down to l.a and [ __ ] too they go
cross country bro
he just got back from north carolina he
drove some ladies one bedroom apartment
what to san diego how could that be
worth it they just paid six thousand
dollars move their stuff but they
probably got the money [ __ ] it
some people were just like that's how
much it cost nine thousand dollars
great damn [ __ ]
you just bought new stuff yeah seriously
what's better than buying new [ __ ] man
like i told you we [ __ ] up and went
and tried out moving to texas for a
couple months
just a horrible mistake yeah but we had
to test it out
but uh we hired a moving company and we
lost a lot of our [ __ ] in the process
this happens all the time and then when
we got back
there was no better feeling than buying
a new bed
with a new blanket and laying in it
after having slept in a
[ __ ] airbnb for the past three months
like just new [ __ ]
it was almost the best feeling in life
backing back in cali like
[ __ ] it's over and you just got your new
[ __ ] yeah
so i know we went out track guys but
marty got a new house
crazy let's go back to the story time
that we introduced that we never got i
thought we were mid-story there yeah no
we didn't start yet okay yeah good
guys here's a story time usually you
know i like to talk about some stuff and
end it today i'ma start it and end it so
here we go
first car that's what i talked about the
reason i brought it up because i was
said [ __ ] the new car i have a new car
stop being a dick about it and just wrap
it and put rims on it and be [ __ ]
psyched anyway the reason i brought it
up because
this story is about the first time i
ever bought a car all right
and like i said i've been working my ass
off trying to make money since
four five four or five
is when i realized if i do that
50 times i can go buy that [ __ ]
wrestler
like i would do [ __ ] for nickels and
dimes around my house like oh
grandma she's like yeah you wanna clean
the blinds my all right cool yeah i'll
give you
35 cents to do a go yup [ __ ] yeah
i'll take your 35 cents do you want the
other room clean
[ __ ] yeah grandma we used to bet on gin
rummy my grandma dolores we used to play
gin rummy hands and bet
so i had better nickels and by the end
of it i had like four more dollars
michael
[ __ ] i'm getting the rock i'm getting
mankind
like i was that kid uh but [ __ ] i've
been paying and growing and like
working for my own [ __ ] the first job i
ever had i was four or five
i built the whole acre fence with my dad
across my grandma's
before it's still up the barbed wire
fence i remember putting it in with the
pole
picking out the pole wrapping the barbed
wire cut the [ __ ] out of myself
on the farm or like in the hood barber
no my grandpa's uh grandma
the ball and grandma and grandpa out in
the country yeah they have all those
acres
for all the cows that's what i was doing
um i used to do whatever i could man i
used to do anything i could i collected
cans i collected
you guys have heard the story times but
anyway
i've been making money so i was a little
kid even though it's a little bit um
first car
the first time everybody carl was 14
years old just turned 14
and um my uncle the reason i brought up
the moving companies my uncle jaime
moved to portland so that's why i moved
to oregon when i got kicked out of
my house with my dad remember i moved to
oregon because my uncle already lived
there
um my uncle was making almost a little
more than a million something dollars
about the movie coming in a year yeah so
that's really your job
out there when you're trying because my
dad was trying to get clean my uncle's
like hey
you're my brother i'll pay 25 bucks an
hour just to drive the truck wow
you know i mean he's like [ __ ] it my
brother i'm gonna get him
so that changed your dad's life
basically yeah he needed to come i mean
my dad's
always worked he he's a trucker i hate
my dad every time i call oh you know
just driving from stockton to l.a i'm
seeing what you can do tonight like damn
dad
he does this my dad is the hardest
working person i ever met my whole
[ __ ] life hands down the hardest
working guy i've ever i remember he
i used to feel lazy like waking up like
oh okay let's go do this move my dad's
already up making coffee
all right [ __ ] this this fool's twice my
age i gotta get my ass up
so the workout that comes from my dad
for sure and my mom my mom's a hard ass
worker
but um here we go i move i went to
oregon
did the whole moving thing that's a
whole side story i went to do a whole
moving thing for like two and a half
weeks right
did it for two and a half weeks got 20
like 300
i believe it was 2700 bucks enough for a
car
a used car so i went back to merced
spent it all on drugs and alcohol like a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
hold on you stacked up for your first
car in two weeks dude it took me
[ __ ] two weeks but 18 hour days
though and getting paid
uh 14 bucks an hour
fast bro fast and tips
when you're a mover people tip
especially a 14 year old they're like
oh you're really strong i used to do
things through this thing where
i have this trick when i used to do
moves is i would pick up the cat the
whole big big
love seats all the huge ones by myself
and then be like that
are you okay my yeah i'm fine but what i
do is i put all the weight on my arm and
my neck
i'd be carrying out a full futon sofa
and those are [ __ ]
heavy but i would just pick up the
biggest [ __ ] and walk it out the door
and not touch the door and the customer
would always be like that
like yeah [ __ ] and i always get i only
got fat tips all the time or picking up
fridges by yourself
there's a way you can grab it there's a
little like the
metal in the back you can like hook your
finger and hook it on the side of the
other front door and just
and you can walk that [ __ ] out yourself
like on your chest
like that but you look like a monster
doing it i used to do it all the time to
[ __ ] with people
but uh tips i got a hell of money
spent it all on alcohol and drugs like
an [ __ ]
then i came back to oregon when i got
kicked out uh i know before that
i came back to oregon worked again got
some more money
i had like i didn't spend all the 2700
on drugs and alcohol but i was down to
like 1200 bucks man
for reals down like 1200 from
almost 3 000 i felt like a piece of [ __ ]
with nathan gomez and joe i just did
drugs
anyway went back to oregon and i said
you know what [ __ ] it i had a little i
had a couple hundred more bucks
um it's before i started selling weed
and um
yeah i went and bought a car so here's
the story i know there's so much build
in my stories this always takes so long
and i get aggravated myself like hurry
the [ __ ] up dude in my own brain but i
have to say these things to set this
yeah
so my uh brother martin he's
he's uh by marriage but he's my brother
right um
he is four years younger than me and i
was 14 so he's about 10 turning 11.
me and him by ourselves go to downtown
86 or not downtown 82nd
street in portland oregon is where
or west 82nd or 182nd street i can't
remember but there's a long
marty there is a five mile
lane of car dealerships every
uh every business is a car dealership
there's no brakes
just pick your price range and keep
walking
all like used cars in portland for some
weird reason
so i started walking around some and you
know little 14 year old me
and my littler smaller brother
just walking around portland i have a
stack of money in my [ __ ] pocket
and i'm just walking through dealerships
and no one's taking me serious she goes
like look at this little boy
oh it's nice oh yeah it's a little
little scratched right there you know
like i'm actually assessing everything
like nah i don't like that
uh what do you have for this much i
remember one guy blew me off
um and i walked to one other one
and uh i walked in
and i find a dodge intrepid green 1996
dodge intrepid
my first car i ever got you're looking
it up oh i missed that car i missed that
car
green dodge 1990 oh there it is that
[ __ ] first and third pick
on the right one more oh that's my car
that's my first car i ever bought so i'm
14 years old i look at the man i have no
license i don't even have a [ __ ]
driver that was my first question
no i don't have a license i know i don't
have one i'm just
gonna try [ __ ] it i got money i'll do it
i was really i was really only looking
around to look at it
and then have somebody my mom my stepmom
or my dad come and buy it
but my no patience ass went
i think i can get away with this right
now so i go up to the man
and i'm like hey i would like to buy
this
car how much do you want what what's the
price the price is on the windshield
because it's a used car dealership but
i'm still like so what's the price i'm
trying to like come off
professionally no no i never barter i
[ __ ] can't stand it
i just went so how much is it i was
hoping he would be like
i'll give you a deal so i was gonna
leave it at that it was uh fourteen
hundred dollars
and i could see the sticker on it that
price
hella big stickers and he's like
so you want to buy this car and i'm like
i might as well have stacked a sat on my
brother's shoulders in a trench cone
like
sir i would like to buy this adult car
that's how i was like
yeah you know i looked at some other
cars but this one's like you know in my
price range i like this one
it's like yeah it's a dodge i was like i
was really trying to
like you know collects all your auto
knowledge on i have none in my whole
family's mechanics power uh seat belts
yeah power seat belts [ __ ] off
so he's like so do you have a license
but my
actually i forgot my license at the
house but i could have my stepmom bring
it
and i'm just playing it off like i got
that [ __ ]
he's like uh let me i'll be right back
maybe it's his wife but it's the other
lady they seem to know each other well
obviously they were together but
the way they were talking they're
definitely husband and wife and she
comes over so
uh you want to buy this car i'm like
yeah i have my and as soon as i pull the
money out she goes
sell in the car walked off sell them the
car she had like that
she's a white white couple older like
60s she had that super
short haircut that all those older white
ladies have
i actually got a haircut today and the
lady next to me was getting the old
white lady haircut
but she was like 50 not old yet and
that's when she went
oh i'm just you know i'm just [ __ ]
i'm old now and she she got that old
lady white
lady haircut that's what i thought of
when you said oh that's mimi po uh
mimi bovic bovic i love drew carey's
show
she was funny used to watching my
grandma dolores i love drew carey show
not that haircut alright man not that
haircut
it was more like drew carey than
anything okay it's a super short
short haircut but it has like ellen
no that's owen wilson i'll find it
i'll find it all right i'll send you a
picture and put it up on the screen all
right i know exactly what
what to go to get anyway sell it to him
damn i'm dragging the story out how long
are we into this podcast 32
a [ __ ] let's go so i'm like
oh right uh yeah i left my id she goes
that's okay oh my god we're gonna need a
driver's license number though
and i call i had my brother martin call
his mom which is my stepmom
and she gave us her license number
yeah they knew what was going on oh so
you have a license like they they were
like
get the money from this [ __ ] kid and
let him crash the car who gives us
that's how they were thinking like
get it out of here uh he said we have a
license number you must have the fraud
they knew what was up it's portland it's
a huge 600
card it's not 2005.
uh no 1996. oh yeah this was damn hold
on 96.
a 96.00 intrepid no no i'm talking about
how what year it was
oh um i graduated in 2007 and i was
going into my sophomore year i was in my
sophomore year so what's that
whatever that is two thousand four
thousand four or five yeah
damn that's a long time i know oh my god
i'm doing the math that's right when i
bought mine
oh my god okay so you guys ready
i'm trying not to do this to my brother
martin that's next to me going oh my
[ __ ] god i'm trying not to freak out
i can see him like
bro we're gonna get the car like oh my
god they're gonna sell us a car
he's on the phone with his mom she's
given the nice license oh
oh yeah your id yeah your your license
this is the number like
we're playing like oh she has your id
here's your license number i forgot it
i look like a little boy now when i was
[ __ ] 14 years old i'd look like a
child
and they're selling a kid a toddler a
[ __ ] car
so here we go ready i get in the car
and i start leaving and as i'm leaving
i'm like yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and i drive out
and i leave and i go i just start
screaming from
like inside of my stomach just ah
like freaking the [ __ ] out my brother
martin is going
just crazy we have no money left i
didn't know about taxes
um no i mean i know about taxes i didn't
know about well you know your plates
this cost and this cost sure oh man
and they wanted me to have insurance we
use this mom insurance number
bro they were giving uninsured 11 and 14
year old a car
it was pretty stupid um i didn't know
had you even like been
driven before i've been driving so i was
five all right
yeah my whole family's a truck driver so
i've been driving diesels
and they sit there and i drive down the
dirt roads to get the loads so why we
get off the main road my dad will let me
drive
but he'd be real close in case i [ __ ]
up but we go on the dirt roads and to
haul tomatoes
and i was driving the diesels on 99 i
was like five or six
damn but he i used to sit on my dad's
lap if i drove on the freeway or the
streets
but if i was on the dirt road he would
sit in the seat next to me and just like
be ready to but you teach me uh-huh
shift downshift dude i can downshift and
all that [ __ ] like seven
a [ __ ] diesel right so yeah i know
how to drive i don't drive well
so i got in the car took off
started driving and like i said i didn't
know about the extra little
this and that oh you want this oh well
that like
it ended up only being like because
important there's no sales tax
in the state of oregon you don't have to
pay taxes 1600
is 1600 okay but they hit me with like
an extra 75
and this and that oh you want the extra
key
[ __ ] i don't i didn't tell this in
story time i forgot to talk about that
they hit me with like 70 [ __ ] dollars
in fees
and that's all the money i had so i was
hoping there was gas in the car
yeah they started to drive 10 miles home
so as we drive off we're screaming two
little babies driving a car
just screaming and i go spicy chicken
sandwiches from carl's jr he goes
[ __ ] yeah and then we're in the
drive-through and i realized
oh my god i think i spent all my [ __ ]
money so i looked at and i had enough
for two spicy chicken sandwiches
we both ate them in my car and i
remember i looked at martin like martin
we're eating spicy chicken sandwiches in
my car and driving home
you know i'm a kid he's a kid like
there's nobody with us what the [ __ ]
this is
incredible middle school uh
pretty he was for sure he was and he's a
badass little kid when he was a kid so
he was fine with that but bro i remember
i drove off
i'm driving and i remember every cop i
tried to do this one
like look off so they didn't know this
little child like because i looked like
i had a baby ass face i had long hair
look like a little
rosie o'donnell type of [ __ ]
character
so made it home pulled up showed my dad
he goes what the [ __ ]
bought a car he was no [ __ ] he was
kind of like
you drove it they let you drive like
that i don't know what the [ __ ] just
happened but they let me drive the car
home and martin's sitting there like
yeah we just used her license id and his
stepmom was with it
i mean my stepmom and his mom was with
it she was cool about it
it was just shocking so yeah go ahead
and drive it he told her in spanish like
no we're gonna drive it home we're safe
blah blah blah
and she's like yeah no problem so we
drove the car
10 miles back from 82nd or 182nd street
to
clackamas and clackamas a little past
the safeway
safeway is where i lived and uh that's
how i bought my first car
not done you ready all right i still had
to drive it back to merced
right i can't drive it my dad would have
said
thomas i can't let you drive it back to
merced from portland it's 711 miles
so it's a 12 hour drive because but your
sister
can drive and you go with her like dad
she's 16.
you're really gonna let us drive back
are you [ __ ] stupid
and he let us drive back and i can't
remember i kept thinking like
all right my first road trip of my life
without anybody else
what do we need so my sister had this
little bong
glass shitty glass bong and a fit in the
center console
but it didn't close so the top of the
bomb would stick out
so we just set it in there and smoked in
the center console leaned in and smoked
bowls
we drove off we got a lot of candy we
got a bunch of
junk [ __ ] we had wheat shireen had a jar
of weed
which was crazy to me before i started
selling anything
like [ __ ] you got more than 20 with the
weed like
what the [ __ ] is happening and
i remember the feeling of
looking at my sister wow
i'm growing up i guess that's 14 years
old
there's oh my god there's a eighth
[ __ ] there's a quarter a week like
there's a jar it was
nothing under 10 grams
and i'm like we're driving holy
[ __ ] let's go and remember when we hit
the freya
freeway i was like wait what
oh my god because in between that time i
had gone home i bought the car
left it there went home came back with
my sister
on a train we took a train from merced
to portland
so we could drive back and um yeah i
came all the way back to merced to get
my sister and then go back
how [ __ ] i was dedicated for that car
i really wanted that car
anyway we're driving back guys the story
sorry i know story's getting a little
long but here we go ready go we're
driving back my sister drives
all the way back we just hit
sacramento
that's a long drive that's about 680 700
miles no it's about 650 miles right
maybe i don't know and my sister drives
the entire thing we're smoking bowls i'm
packing bowls for her she leans over to
hit the bong while driving and i light
it pull the ball
she doesn't look away and drive she has
times i drive good but this is i never
really drive with a bomb but don't worry
i'll light it all
so i was lighting the bong i'm hitting
the bong i never even owned a
bong before and i always make my bongs
out of bottles i'm like smoking i
remember i'm looking up blowing smoke
i'm like i
own this car i mean i mean like that's
like
it's setting in like wow i own the car
this is my [ __ ] car and then we're
driving get to sacramento and my sister
goes i'm
i'm i can't i'm falling asleep can you
please drive and go [ __ ] yeah i can
drive
[ __ ] yeah i can drive my my car get in
my car
hyped start driving i only get to
modesto which is not
that far from sacramento
and i fell asleep while driving are you
ready
my grandma dolores head
oh wow wait wait wait wait wait wait
there's a gap i bought the car when i
was 14.
left it there for a month
it was months i left it there
yeah i left there for a while then came
back my grandma delores had already
died i believe i think i think she
already died because
something was watching over us right or
driving damn that time
is so weird to me right now when did my
grandma die i can't remember what age
now
[ __ ] that's weird anyway
i'm driving by modesto and i know
modesto well it's about 45 minutes away
from merced
and modesto has a good mall so we go
there
or fresno anyway we're in modesto i'm
like oh my god i can't wait
i'm gonna call my [ __ ] hot i know
exactly i'm gonna show up just not even
telling [ __ ] i'm just gonna show up in
the car like
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna show up with a car and
uh it's like 11
30 at night man so i'm driving
i get to modesto i see the bridge right
by the
the mall the overpass i remember i see
it
my sister's dead asleep and i and she's
a dick so i don't want to be like i'm
falling asleep you piece of [ __ ] can't
[ __ ] try she's a
[ __ ] dick and uh
i'm driving i remember i'm just like all
right cool i'm driving
and i closed my eyes closed i remember
seeing my eyes closed marty
and when i opened my eyes i got like oh
okay and i look at my rear view mirror
and that overpass is
almost out of my sight so i was driving
for about 40 seconds
jesus dad asleep 40 seconds
on a freeway going 80 bong in the middle
14 like 15.
i woke up saw i was like oh damn oh
[ __ ] i fell asleep saw the rear of you
realized how long i'd been to sleep and
started screaming
i started screaming at the top of my
lungs because i didn't want to fall
asleep again i needed her to wake up
you know i was at that point where i'm
like just trying to
like some of you right now in the
[ __ ] car right now i'm trying to stay
awake that was me
window open don't do [ __ ] candy nope
nothing was working
i was done so i started
pulled off the freeway we switched
places
right on the side of the freeway she was
[ __ ] screaming at me
hella mad that i didn't drive but
i fell asleep what the [ __ ] you want to
do anyway she drove home
and that's how i bought my first car so
i got bought and got my first car
yeah kids die like that all the [ __ ]
time yeah
all the time i got in a real bad
accident like that did you
[ __ ] how old were you
19. oh damn i i got in like three or
four
real bad accidents right in a row that
like weren't my fault
or i wasn't driving yeah
yeah i think oh i told you about the one
where my boy fell asleep at the wheel
but
we rented a 300c to drive oh you told me
all that city yeah yeah
that's a good one though yeah yeah yeah
that was that was horrible
we run it we were doing one of those
showcases i was telling you about
so my boy who was older than us we were
19. my boy that was like 27
28 rented us a car to drive down to
manhattan
and he got us a 300 c which was like it
might as well have been a [ __ ]
wraith at the time yeah the [ __ ]
rolls royce i had never driven a car
that was beyond like a [ __ ]
escort at that point so we we were
[ __ ] really really really
[ __ ] feeling ourselves me and my two
boys so we drove down to
manhattan uh i drove the whole way
because
he wasn't with us the dude that put the
rented the car he rated it with faith
you guys didn't return it
yeah yeah but he didn't get insurance
either
so there was that so he like i felt like
he
like doomed like he put like a hack
because he i remember vividly he handed
me the keys
and he's like don't wreck this [ __ ]
car
dead ass serious and he was like a lot
older than me
at the time this is my boy we just know
we're just boys but i'm
19 he's 27.
so anyway i'm like yeah no problem of
course not
i we go down there do the showcase hop
in drive right back i drive
us through man this is we didn't even
have google maps i was doing this so
much at this point i wasn't even
printing out directions anymore yeah
so i'm able to find us back from
manhattan
through new jersey through pa i get us
up into pa and like scranton and we
start it's like
three in the morning at this point and
we start going
back up we're gonna go into new york hit
syracuse and
go over three hours back to buffalo so
once we start getting into pa on the
freeway i'm
my boy had been sleeping for like a
couple hours so i'm like
i tell him like i'm gonna sleep for a
minute you drive
so he's driving we're going down the
freeway we got the 300 seat going it's
got the [ __ ] carolina blue
lights going on on the inside and [ __ ]
we just did the showcase i'm feeling
good
he just slept for a while so i'm like
all right i'm finally relaxed
every time we go i'm the only one that
drives because we're taking my dad's
[ __ ] station wagon or whatever the
case was
so or whoever i was with did never
license so
my boy takes over and we're in the right
hand lane and i'm starting to fall
asleep
and then i see him like go into the
left-hand lane i'm not thinking nothing
of it
but then he kind of keeps going like
he's not changing lanes
oh he's asleep he's just drifting so
then i say
he wakes up doesn't matter we slam into
the [ __ ] median
as soon as we slam into the median
everything on the dash lights up i
didn't i remember seeing it because i'd
never seen
anything like that before four this
tire's out that tire's out this tire's
out this is broke that's broke that's
broke that's where just like
everything's going off on the dash
we're in the [ __ ] middle of nowhere 3
a.m me and my two homies we all got the
[ __ ] 3xyt's on and [ __ ]
with the bootleg jays and all that [ __ ]
so
the dickies and man they were off ebay
they were clean
but wait
listen there's definitely [ __ ] fake
jays of course
would you but like people buy them and
not know
yeah yeah i mean is that good i mean
there was a stretch where you might
get i don't [ __ ] know listen i had i
have a stellar j career i'm gonna throw
i don't know what i mean
i remember in that particular trip i had
some navy blue dickies with some [ __ ]
laser etch jays or some [ __ ] they don't
i don't
in my mind feel like they were official
but i'm just going to throw that out
there
in my mind i'm just being honest here
okay yeah all right so we're out there
anyways in the ghetto basically but
we're not shacks
not at this well here we're in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere country
there's when you crash oh [ __ ] yes
so wait you said that right there yeah
so we're in the country
uh so we gotta call 9-1-1 basically
that's all we got we got i got probably
a [ __ ] trap phone
barely so we uh you know
truck tow truck comes takes us drops us
off at the [ __ ] disclosed
uh auto place it's like four in the
morning at this point
and we're sitting there at this diner
next door and i'm
starting to kind of like not panic but
i'm like thinking
now okay we're in this situation and the
dude whose
name the car is in isn't with us so
that's a problem
and now mind you this is my boy like we
work in the same building i met him in
the [ __ ] basement with
rats and asbestos and sewer [ __ ] going
on in this [ __ ] building we worked in
me and him you sit down there for hours
i went up to him i heard him rapping
walking down the halls rapping his
[ __ ] ass off
i'm in this little room doing all the
files i'm like man you like hip-hop i
put
i gave him my mixtape just in the
[ __ ] basement down there used to
stand on there and talk for hours we
became best friends
but he's straight on the east side like
he grew up like
is [ __ ] deadly over there and he he
grew up in the
70s and 80s and [ __ ] he was a little bit
older than me
oh man so anyway i call him and i'm like
yo
so-and-so crash the car he goes no he
didn't
just hangs up i'm like [ __ ]
no he didn't that's all he said yeah
you're like what no now yous can't leave
that's what i hear [ __ ] out of here
so yeah so now my boy is like he's
like yeah is he a scary dude
yeah i mean this is a dude that's been
in shootouts this is a dude that's been
through everything you could imagine
we're young
compared to him got you but we all you
wouldn't know it he looks like he's our
age
no he didn't yeah that's all he said
yeah
that's scary keep going i'm very
interested i don't remember this part of
the episode i mean
yeah my boy is damn near crying i'm like
pacing around
we're in this diner we're waiting for
what's gonna happen
we don't have any barely any [ __ ]
money to begin with i'm the only one
with the job but that
so uh stress if this is killing me yeah
oh my god
yeah uh i called my parents i think
my dad was just like like uh
all right well good luck with that was
basically what i got from him
uh you know so
we go to the car repair place in the
morning
and when we get there i mean we're
waiting for it basically like we go in
there we let them know what happens we
leave
we go and we're burning more hours just
[ __ ] walking around this random
nowhere town
we come back a couple hours later
they're going to let us know what the
deal is with the car
and when we walk in a cop pops out he
was hiding behind the counter
and he shut the [ __ ] up i don't remember
this part
i don't know if i [ __ ] told you stop
they were waiting for you to come back
in the comments
let me hide yes he popped up he was
crouching down behind the counter and he
popped up and said put your hands on the
counter
because they thought we robbed the car
because the dude whose name it was in
wasn't with
us so
[Music]
that's when this whole situation started
to unfold then we started [ __ ] lying
and our lie i mean we were lying in the
sense that we were like he came down
with the showcase and
somebody died back in buffalo and he had
to leave before us and we're on our way
back now
but we hadn't really [ __ ] a lie bro
because then you might like
who died some [ __ ] why would you say
something somebody got
shot so he had some something i don't
know it was something fun this is on the
[ __ ] fly
no sleep i know yeah somebody got
murdered
and there's a graduation today yeah
then whatever we said wasn't what he
said when they called him
so they called him what happened and
they they
realized we were lying so what what
happened first was there was some back
and forth like
they're looking at us like who are these
[ __ ] fools mind you
you know like just off the jump like you
know with the 300 out there with all the
boxes of mixtapes and [ __ ] like yeah
and then so then uh the cop ends up
giving us a ride to the train station
before they realized that we weren't
telling them the truth
he gives us a ride to the train station
and then when we get there we call my
boy back in buffalo and he had been
talking to the insurance company
he now the repair place and the
insurance company is aware
that where all our stories like aren't
driving whatsoever
and now we're at this like train station
slash
plaza and we're seeing the cops like
circling around
and we're like literally looking for you
yeah
because yeah you were lying because we
got on the phone with my boy back in
buffalo and he told us like yo they know
that they know like i'm not with us
they're like
they're trying they said they're gonna
like sue me for all this money and [ __ ]
like i don't know what the [ __ ] you boys
are gonna do
but they're looking for you like this
he's telling them like they're
this is like insurance fraud type [ __ ]
so did you get on the train left yeah we
got on a greyhound we [ __ ] were like
going through like the little these
little hallways and [ __ ] and this little
plaza
we're looking at the cop cars we're like
up against the walls and [ __ ] like
waiting waiting for the bus we saw the
greyhound we went and got on it and
we went back to buffalo came back i had
to buy their tickets got back to buffalo
that like later in the morning i'd
work later that day wait zero dollars
what happened with the car
so i mean he he ended up
he ended up working it out with them
somehow but there was
a probably three months there where he's
like i don't give a [ __ ] if you gotta
rob a bank or whatever the [ __ ] you boys
gotta do i don't give a [ __ ] do it
it was like that and my brother had just
went down for bank robbery
or was about to i can't if i really
wasn't robbing the bank for you was he
no [ __ ] no okay
but it was just when he said that it was
like
damn i think it was i think he was
already in jail for it because i
remember when he said it i'm like that's
almost the [ __ ] low blow
yeah uh so
we we talked it out and worked it out
eventually me and him got back on track
and man [ __ ] we we
worked it out we went on to become
[ __ ] best friends though he's one of
my
you know wedding not so much we haven't
talked since he he was one of my only
boys that move
that came out here to visit me oh no
[ __ ] and
when he did it just like it was really
it was just really weird i could just
tell like oh i'm a lot different now
this was even maybe a year and a half
two years after i moved here
and it was just very much like we we
were like arguing i
was having to like it was uncomfortable
it was just like
it's when people i've noticed when
sometimes when people from buffalo come
out to orange county they're
makes them uncomfortable makes them like
anxious or like i i don't know like it's
just so different
it's so different that
i don't know we just it didn't really go
well and we really haven't talked since
wow but i really haven't i don't i'm not
somebody that talks to people on the
regular
i don't yeah but when i see my boys
there's like it's like nothing it's like
no time has ever gone by
but then a situation like that it's like
i'm sure it would be like that but i
just don't
feel compelled to like really reach out
but that that still is like
one of my all-time best friends and that
was a [ __ ] up situation but
yeah we got through it and i mean we
both we ended up chipping in and he
ended up working it out they didn't sue
him
whatever happened it ended up working
out but that was one of the tensest
situations in my life because
i had already been known like i knew
what it was with him
he was the one that went on when i told
you the whole scenario about
that goofy ass kid when i was like 12
all that how we were terrorizing that
neighborhood and they kicked
the neighborhood made his family move
out of the neighborhood
basically that kid and then he moved to
lackawanna
and then i linked him up with this dude
and his boys with the weed
and then he walked him for it oh he
means he stole the weed guys and didn't
pay for it
because you're slaying over there it's
crazy which put me in a whole new
prediction made you look like you were
in it with it
yeah well he knew i wasn't because then
it took off to
looks like oh i'm sure it was a [ __ ]
horrible look for me i'm just getting
past this goddamn rental situation with
this dude
and then how much wait how much weed 10
pounds if it's under 10 then it's
we're talking ounces we're talking about
answers here oh we
speak in different increments okay
that's a lot to me okay i mean 500 bucks
yeah
that's a lot of [ __ ] weed to us
nobody has more weed than that in my
mind
damn nobody's moving in my world
out there oh yeah okay yeah i get you
the average
nickel bags and time bags [ __ ]
wow i can't imagine growing up like that
but we had successfully
i had plugged my other boys with them
successfully yeah
and then my this goofy [ __ ] moved in
and he's
begging me to plug him so i [ __ ] plug
him and then he [ __ ] walks them and
ends up in utah and it ended up being a
part of me moving out here actually like
we were talking about because he ended
up on a weed farm
he linked up with this [ __ ] dude at
dr dre studio oh and that's how all this
connected yep
that's right up with the dude at the
studio then bam that's who i stayed with
when i came out here
how crazy we talked about him on the
podcast so wow that's really held on
but that was another tense situation
take your two zips to get out of here
basically man they're getting watched
two zips into this [ __ ] yeah so
well i like that so that's the time you
crash the car
yeah that's not my my first car buying
experience wasn't that
romantic man i saved up i shoe boxed and
[ __ ] rubber banded up three grand and
went and got me a 95 miles to [ __ ]
protege seafoam green
hey put two giant turns in the back of
that [ __ ] it had the high performance
muffler on it
also for that guy i hated that [ __ ]
thing i turned i ended up taking it off
it was just
too much for that guy inadvertently
yeah the system my system was everything
yeah and it saved that
livestream that's great i never bumped
dude i mean because i was always i
packed so i had so much weed that wasn't
an issue now
i slumped in the car now because i don't
give a [ __ ] anymore it's awesome
but i get it now my people do it mm-hmm
i never understood man when you're
making music it makes all the difference
that's true too that's what you do yeah
yeah i get it
i get it and the giant are giant the
giant box i took up my whole trunk
another in that same time frame coming
home from the studio somebody just
comes up slams into the back of my car
completely totals the car sends us
across all the lanes of the freeway
slam into the median spin 100 yards down
the freeway
are you a good driver marty listen i was
in the right hand land
listen this goddamn muffler was broken
you've been in four accidents are any of
them your fault
no wow like i'm the okay so i wasn't
even driving this was the one i was
driving for
but somebody i'm in the right hand lane
because that high performance muffler at
the time was [ __ ] broke
and i'm going like regular speed i'm in
the right hand lane we've been in the
studio all day
i'm driving carefully oh wait you told
me about this this [ __ ] just
came and
slammed into the back of me so hard that
it sent us
like that across all of it and then i
blacked out
and i remember rolling backwards down
the freeway smoke [ __ ] everywhere in
a little voice my mind said
you might as well put your foot on the
brake so i stopped the car and i looked
around
and like we were all alive i heard it
audible
it's the only time that's ever happened
that's [ __ ]
scary i heard it
so only time was it your own voice yeah
oh i guess so it's my mind's voice did
it sound like you yeah
then that's yeah
might have been the dude behind me i
don't [ __ ] know but yeah the one dude
swallowed the blunt
that was behind me we were he ingested
the blunt that he
accidentally during the accident
[Laughter]
i just imagine going yeah
that's so tight he will take the whole
blood
oh my god but to my boys my one boy that
looks like [ __ ] biggie smalls he's
like six
six i seen the picture of him he was in
the back seat with my other boy
and this this that huge box kept them
from the smack the impala going into
them
yeah man because when we took it to the
auto shop afterwards these like
people lived in this that's what he said
when i walked up to get my [ __ ] out of
the car
wow yeah and then i
took my little bit of insurance money
and blew it on shitty weed and it was
really shitty in me it was [ __ ]
stupid
because i had just gotten with april i
got with april i had a job
all right a good a decent job at working
in that shitty
rat filled the basement i'm telling you
about a couple weeks after i get with
april
it's getting too thick with the [ __ ]
music i quit the job but she's got a job
so then like i was i was broke for like
10 months
you know what i mean but then yeah this
all came around
so so that's how you moved out here what
a full circle story
i love it [ __ ] was crazy that's awesome
yeah what time are we at
i have a feeling it's at 52 102. oh 60
o'clock
all right damn it we we
we be ranting we be clubbing
okay marty can you do me a favor uh
let's let's let's
see back on track here yeah yeah that
was stuck on the story imagining
snow yeah but oh my sorry my final point
was
it was shitty of me to spend my little
bit of insurance money because april had
been holding [ __ ] down i went and bought
this [ __ ] [ __ ] i was all geeked
up to buy ounces of this 80
[ __ ] zona ounce weed and uh yeah
insurance money but you only spent 80
dollars i only got like a g i bought
some [ __ ]
clothes and some [ __ ] and it was
gone immediately
that was shitty so you know put that out
there
okay now i get you that makes sense yeah
you're a day
are you ready yes guys i have a little
segment in here
all right i wanted to talk to you guys
about this we have
our first time ever doing three ad
reads in an episode we've never done it
before yes ever ever
we try to make them fun trying to make
them like that's why we did the
commercial because we're
we want this to be fun even if we want
you to sit at home go oh that's an
ad oh i'm watching an ad that's right
that's what i want you to do like i
forgot this was an ad
i see the comments only ads i don't skip
mm-hmm that's
[ __ ] awesome bomb so
uh we wanted to liven it up a little bit
i wanted to get some life in here
but by the way thank you guys because
this is what it takes to sustain this
and the only reason we're getting new ad
partners is because the views are
supporting it
that's it yeah period that's what i said
thank you for supporting the brands and
support us
thank you for supporting us thank you
for liking and leaving reviews and
all that [ __ ] it [ __ ] helps so much
and uh this is the best part of the week
this is fun
all right this is fun as [ __ ] for us so
um
i want to try something different marty
can you bring up these questions you
haven't looked at please don't look at
them
so i wanted to bring up some questions
all right
here we go marty these are would you
rather i want to fire these off at you i
want you to
think about this uh-huh and just answer
truthfully
all right you're ready you're bust you
ready these are wild questions
these are all from rosie okay rosie i
don't think it's a question it's not
easy
okay you asked me to think of some some
random questions for you i thought of
the one super random one i'm like this
isn't easy i [ __ ] feel like i know
everything
i know what you're saying but they're
not questions about yourself they're
just
random are you ready yeah yeah no these
are not what you think okay
all right i'm excited to do this would
you rather have the ability to go 10
years in the past or 150 in the future
[ __ ] high-ass rosie
that's a question 150 in the future
would suck
and see and be able to come back or 10
years in the past
and then come back so you can go back in
10 years and kind of redo things
i'm going back 10 years yeah no
no no no [ __ ] no no really no that was
that was a trick answer because
i mean things worked out really or
working out exactly how i wanted to
so i'd go i'd go forward and see what
the [ __ ] is going on
but i mean you might not like what you
see that's the kicker it might be
a horrible move that's a risk and
there's like [ __ ] sick statues of us
like this
just somewhere red like the whole world
runs on weed
it's our all-time resource that's
changed the whole planet
yeah you've been immortalized
uh for me i'd go 10 years
back not change anything and just look
around go damn
this shit's crazy and that's it because
i don't want to go in the future
they feel like go in the future [ __ ]
robot dinosaur steps on me like some
family guy
either might be awesome or shitty yeah
yeah or [ __ ] so sick it could be
it could be sick are you ready that's a
great question
ready and these are all ready would you
rather have everyone
know would you rather have everyone be
able to read your thoughts
or everyone be able to look at your
internet history at all at any time
my thoughts are pretty [ __ ] funny i
would like to put those out there
yeah i love that answer
that would be great i would like a lot
more credit for the thoughts in my head
yes you know what check first yeah
that would be great actually that would
be [ __ ] awesome
yes that would be hilarious but for the
times that you're working on [ __ ] it
would be awful
you're doing new stuff and people just
steal everything you've ever thought
i would like to live life like that
though but what if somebody just steals
every idea you ever thought of as you're
thinking of it go [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
just people just walking up thanks man
no awesome i got a podcast and they walk
away get everything you ever thought of
yeah no more consultation bookings no
more consultations of
all time yeah yeah i'm gonna stick with
that thoughts
yeah i'm going internet history because
i don't give a [ __ ] what you see yeah
there's not
there's nothing really interesting
unless you're into cameras and [ __ ] like
there's not a lot but yo
you know what's one funny thing me and
marty are obviously both on the dope as
usual podcast uh
this obviously this youtube and i can
tell what marty's looking at i mean i
could see what what i'm researching that
day
i'll be getting a bunch of
recommendation but
had a [ __ ] fix of something lens i'm
like what the
[ __ ] and none of my funny shit's there
go hey
uh-huh marty's and i text you what kind
of camera are you looking at
today oh why like there's 36
recommendations for new cameras
and tutorials on how to make [ __ ] a
light box or something stupid it's
useful and i'm over here like where's my
people dying inside compilations
like [ __ ] i'm so ignorant
but you can see i can see it all the
time so in an internet history for me
100 i don't give a [ __ ]
go do all my comments for me that's not
my tube like
you wanna look at my internet history if
you do a hundred comments while i say
the answer
and you just type it [ __ ] yeah i would
love that
bro i do every you see it i don't copy
paste my comments i answer them
imagine it takes so long i love talking
in the afterlife or something you get to
you see like a a a rolling footage of
like your history of all your [ __ ]
comments you've answered and your career
could you imagine i
think or probably take like honestly
i've answered back
at least a thousand for every video for
i'm gonna say
500 000 comments throughout my time no
that's 800 000 comments for sure
on multiple platforms yeah because i'm
thinking about every platform
every dm on your phone on my phone yeah
not pasting not text to talk
no copy paste no text to talk because i
say slang [ __ ] and i always say someone
dumb [ __ ] and then cuz i have to go back
and
hit that's the worst [ __ ] hate that
[ __ ] so internet history for me
here we go see we just got off we're
supposed to be rapid fire are you ready
this is a great one would you rather
have universal damn it rosie
she looked at a website would you rather
have universal respect or unlimited
power
those are a little vague those are a
little vague so basically
would you rather be like mike tyson or
jafar
i'm taking the [ __ ] power i feel like
i've earned my goddamn respect out here
jafar
but what kind of power i want power that
i could just get i could get
[ __ ] that i want done done we want if i
want to get a guest on here
i basically need a blue [ __ ] check
mark that's it
yeah dude um
what so didn't we talk about the other
day
how cool would it be to be able for us
to walk in my life right now
for push trees i walk in and go hey
here's all the orders
thank you you know how to do them all
hey designer here's like the eight
things i'm thinking let's call this
collection
this all right here's eight pictures i
really like the colors of these do your
work with that
boom you go there hey you guys bag uh
manufacturer guys you talked all the
manufacturers
cool i would like this kind of bag this
kind of bag this kind of bag can you
make me like
four template mock-ups of each design i
like black
white maybe like checkerboard on this
one make me four mood boards thank you
come back to my other designers but for
the clothes
you know it's getting hot i want to do
three pairs of shorts on this one can
you give me six designs
for three pairs of shorts so two each
i'll be back can you get done today
thank you
and i'll come over here like all right
so how much do i pay on this all right
cool counting
boom i'm gonna leave because i do all of
that [ __ ]
every [ __ ] day and it takes hours and
rosie too
so if i can go like yo cool boom and
then go all right
dope is yola videos all right cool
videographer
boom all right took six hours sick
because i do the whole edit and then
marty makes it sick as [ __ ] marty takes
more time to edit than i do and i take
like six hours
it takes that long to edit our videos
because they're so damn detailed in the
overlays and b-rolls and crazy dope [ __ ]
but it's worth it it's [ __ ] awesome
but i can walk up and go hey editor you
know how i like to edit right
cool boom as soon as you're done send
that to marty so he can just do the sick
[ __ ]
you're gonna be done cool all right done
adventures yolo channel hey a
videographer okay
let's go knock this [ __ ] thing out
all right cool done that's all in one
day though
then we come to the podcast if you can
have two of you like cool do this clip
we'd like this clip someone's sitting
there
you're just like that mm-hmm yeah when
you do that that means
time stamp quick side note we're still
in the process of hiring
things have changed a little bit wedding
bro yeah yeah i'm sweating
side note to everybody out there though
we i appreciate all the applications
that we got we're making some changes
and
we are still hiring so that's going to
be drastic graphics is hiring
once and we're not looking for people
that are willing to learn and grow
this is a business okay we have to you
have to be able we are looking for
people that are willing to learn
no no i'm talking about like i don't
know computers but i'm willing to learn
and grow
like no do you know like all these
programs now you can learn and grow
within that yeah that's not what i mean
i mean like yeah i'm not sure i have
people hit me up
i'll be a videographer i mean i've never
taken pictures or
i'm down i'm down too
[ __ ] i need help man i can't be all
right so let's take eight weeks to
teach but i need a video tomorrow like
oh
and i would love to we got a lot of
great candidates all the time yeah we
got a lot of great candidates and
we're gonna be building out the team
more so standard so drastic graphics
make sure you check it out where where
can they find the application thing or
graphics.com
if you brought my instagram you'll see a
video from about a month ago that's on
there it says we're hiring a giant
letter so
that'll be the one um so yes
dude i got overwhelmed even thinking
about having that many people do all my
work
that was you did a great cruella
impression yesterday when you were
talking about the movie when she walked
in and how she came in the office
oh when i watched corello with emma
stone ago so
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] of the movie
the cruella's basically turns into
essentially right because we know one of
the dalmatians
the lady walked in and went i need five
looks don't like that cut that off
you're [ __ ] fired all right cool
good this is dog [ __ ] you're fired too
all right cool done done
she walked out of her place [ __ ] ate
her food was done walked in nine minute
power nap it's one o'clock
shut the [ __ ] up nine minutes come out
you have two meetings okay thank you
uh the person walking like yes this this
this this dude thanks thanks
alvaro that's my dream bro yeah alpha
brain vermont
no lie i'm very excited for that yeah
because i do all of this
with these damn headaches yeah and being
tired all the times i can't sleep
if i can just be more like efficient
yeah it's vitamins for the brain i just
really
i i just thought about all that because
we run four [ __ ] businesses
essentially
and it's so draining bro i love doing
it's my favorite thing in the world i'm
gonna be up till [ __ ] six o'clock but
within the podcast even there's so many
different facets between
the podcasts the content of the show
yeah we do everything
shooting the promo videos like you know
to even today we did like three hours of
[ __ ] filming
just for the [ __ ] honor just just to
do the little commercial took
two hours you know it took two hours i
was in two
solid hours and all i did was work out
and then i went home going
i'm gonna throw up i think i'm so out of
shape
you just worked out for two solid hours
holding it for pictures like
holding weights and [ __ ] um i'm tired
anyway i feel overwhelmed thinking about
being overwhelmed
that's how bad it is but i keep it
together but i'm just saying if i could
have those people
push trees would be two of these
warehouses you're gonna mean dopes y'all
would be able to have two videos the
dopestyle channel two videos a week
that's the goal what's the call man i
just need more help i need more help
come in and you're ready to go turn key
people and you turn keep yeah i mean
for me i mean it's like we set we set
this long-term goal of even getting this
thing up and running now there's all
these little mining goals and milestones
we have to head towards brandon now
helping us we have another
yeah we're looking to onboard a booking
agent too so that's going to really help
that's
about to get a booking agent because me
and marty are like all right so we have
to hit up every single one of these
people follow up with all these things
okay how many clips you got all right
cool we got this all right i'm gonna
upload oh [ __ ] we gotta do this we have
15 clips okay let me upload them all let
me do all the things all
if you upload on youtube to do all the
time stamps and all the
clips and then it takes two hours to
but i mean it's like not complaining
it's just wow
yeah i literally have 22 hours of work
today yeah we just got to structure
things
well but the the beautiful part now is
that there's like light at the end of
the tunnel with these new
like partnerships that we have that
we're going to love all the [ __ ] yeah i
would not change anything i mean
changing the thing is
more helpful but i if i have to do this
for 50 years by my i'll [ __ ] do it
rosie helps so much she does all the
computer [ __ ] for push trees
because that's not even included in
everything i just said yeah and she did
six hours a day yeah for sure all
six hours at least just on the computer
doing stuff
just for post-truth stuff because we get
a lot of orders man well she handles all
the e-commerce
me and rosie pack all the orders took me
[ __ ] 12 hours working with the
artists
working with the manufacturers all the
meetings
waiting for samples a guy that just does
that
like nobody could do that though nobody
could no no and then i go
thomas i'm ready come in like yeah yeah
dog [ __ ] dog [ __ ] that's sick as [ __ ]
bro keep going different colors i [ __ ]
with that
and i walk out and back to filming yes i
do that all the time already but it's
like
i'm trying to play six roles and i'm
like
i just smoked four grams of hash in this
video i'm [ __ ] up and we gotta do a
podcast tonight
my life is like uh have you seen uncut
gems no
i was talking about it when they when me
and justin were talking about it there's
a scene in there where there's like five
things happening at once and kevin
garnett's stuck in this box you're
trying to get him into a shop and
people are calling and this is going
that's my life every [ __ ] damn like
okay [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i got 46 text messages
[ __ ]
all right let me make these fools back
oh constant stay the [ __ ]
yeah i [ __ ] forgot oh [ __ ] i just
need an assistant to go thomas
don't book that for tuesday you have 12
things to do tuesday thanks
yeah that's all man it's just it's just
a lot and i'm a
we non-stop you're like me we will work
until it's done yeah so it's like i'll
sleep
at six i don't give a [ __ ] but you're
not like i i can't sleep
i cannot sleep so this works at [ __ ]
five in the morning and i'm
up until seven and you work off damn day
but our schedules are just flipped
i sleep i take the night shift basically
that's actually nice though because like
when you wake up i have a bunch of [ __ ]
kind of ready to go yeah
it's true it's like yeah it's like uh
when i have clients in different time
zones it's nice
we live 45 minutes away from each other
and my brain's deteriorating from the
nose
well you're up to you're like uh i
stayed up till five in the morning
editing two videos last night and just
because
edit two videos and one [ __ ] night
the other night yo what time we're
getting so off track
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
let's get back to the rapid fire
questions
i don't have a joint let's let's let
this joint you ready wow
let's get back on this question would
you rather spend a year in prison or a
year at war
i'm going prison depending on which war
yeah these are both wars yeah which
one's guaranteed to live yeah
i mean yeah
that's [ __ ] tough it depends if we're
at [ __ ] war or not thank you because
if it's like
if we're dirt it's an active war i can
play call of duty
yeah that's like what am i getting to
the drone program
but i've seen my homie just got back
from prison and he was snapchatting me
the whole time he was in prison during
all the years he was there
see i think i might kill myself in
prison i can't
take a [ __ ]
appointment without getting anxiety of
like i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
i can't be in this room this is taking
up too much of my time now you know what
i think what happened
everybody like that fool's really good
at basketball
yo put them on our team it might
actually be sick i might just devote my
life to basketball for a year yeah but
no no i try to get out
yeah no this is kind of great going down
next month
yeah yeah all right jail it is
chill it is right you'd be all right
wait no no i know who produced that no
no no i i
i i was doing that okay you're duncan
too
[ __ ] it marty can't dunk you said though
i imagine i'm already dunking
i can dunk it just has to be a lowered
rim [ __ ] out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here or a slam ball
style situation
slam ball was the [ __ ] right now if you
do not remember slam ball if you're on
the computer open another page while
this is blind i explained it to cam
last night and he's jaw-dropped why
isn't the sport today
no idea it's basketball ready
it's basketball but there's like eight
built-in floor trampolines so
every dunk is a 12-foot flip it's
nba jam in real life
you bringing it up yeah i was looking
here because i thought i read something
about that
look at that that's the og
it's like harlem globetrotters but it's
like full contact
full contact and when you go up you're
allowed to smack each other
like hockey yes so they're taking off
from
two three trampolines back 15 feet
fools was literally the first time i
ever saw someone do
pop your collar remember that was
popular the first time i ever saw
someone do that was during the
championship again of the first
championship
and they won and some guy walked up the
players and did that to everyone's shirt
while they're getting interviewed
what the [ __ ] is the guy doing and i saw
everybody at school talking about the
song i'm like
oh he was doing cool stuff okay yeah he
was doing trendy things went over my
head yeah
i'm [ __ ] completely why is he doing
that to everyone's shirt
what a weird memory but anyway [ __ ] yeah
let's hope they bring back [ __ ] slams
this is a slam ball see we go too off
topic what about we're talking about war
and
year in prison year of war and now we're
in the slam ball jail slam ball
i don't know that bro you let the
inmates go at it and [ __ ] slam ball
that's what people want to see oh no
that's a good one inmates versus
influencers
[Laughter]
what about inmate influencers okay
yeah you got charlie sheen in there oh
i'm talking about inmates that are in
there that are influencers too
you haven't seen these tick tock guys
man you know i don't know what the [ __ ]
is going on on tick tock
that's right dude with the right ones
yeah so tight
it's like vine yeah my algorithm is just
crazy [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
behind vine [ __ ] anyway there's fools in
jail in prison they have full on tick
tocks
anyway my homie just got out of prison
and he was snapping me in prison
for like four years or whatever and i
always get a snap from go
what are you doing what are you doing
that's fun [ __ ]
and every [ __ ] time he was doing
something awesome
i'm not kidding remember when the popeye
chicken sandwich craze was going on
yeah i had a day one in prison and he
literally snapped me like yo yo check it
out check it out
like three of them and i got a kfc one
just like to test it
like a huge piece of [ __ ] and he had he
bought a rolex and got it in there and
he was wearing it
in his cell phone i didn't even go oh i
said it it's my homie and i go oh full
why do you have he goes i mean i'm just
sitting here bro i'm just fine it's
tight
all right i'll take it back you're bored
yeah totally get it full head [ __ ]
killing time
yes oh get the [ __ ] that events
get out of here i love it love that [ __ ]
he would he would facetime me on
instagram and [ __ ] like where you do the
facetime chat the last time was like two
years
before he got out but he was like she
set the phone up because what's up fool
he's like oh oh because he did fire camp
where you like get released and go to be
a firefighter yeah and so like
last year he was a firefighter or
whatever and he's facetiming me he's
like what's up
like yo you're a buff as [ __ ] now okay
cuz yeah my uh
sergeant's outside but uh i got two
minutes what's up [ __ ]
yo i got anxiety for you right now i'm
literally waiting for the door to open
like a movie
and you get more time can you turn the
[ __ ] phone off
i was like well bro please keep an eye
out i'm not that important yes like
don't do this
and he's looking over he's like i can
see from where they're at don't worry i
can see him walk up and go oh okay
so we had like a 10 minute conversation
and then phil was just like
so i'm like yo you have no hair cause he
had hair down to his ass when he went
like yo you look like a buff grown scary
white man now
anyway uh prison looked [ __ ]
awesome for him that's why i brought it
up prisoner you're like
well depending on what prison i go to
yeah i might go to prison yeah i
follow some war history instagram
accounts those are
interesting follows yeah you don't i
don't follow anything besides weed [ __ ]
on my page so i don't
mix my brain up with anything else and
if i only have weed pages
um i don't know man i just there's too
much [ __ ] going
on in the day can we go back i'm [ __ ]
lost
all right we're out 25 here would you
rather be in a zombie apocalypse
or a robot apocalypse zombies zombies
are [ __ ] stupid thank you
hold on regular zombies
but what about 28 days later zombies
where they're running full
[ __ ] olympics marathon sp sprints
all you got to do is get up high have
you seen the movie
no because
i still take zombies and me and justin
were just talking about he's just
blowing o's
look at him by himself he's pulling
smoke rings over there wow that was the
most boss [ __ ] i ever saw oh jesus
christ we were talking about iro buddy
and he was like
so i'm just gonna wet him right
we just pour water i'm like yo water gun
i robot
finish the whole movie a whole different
movie at that point scarface
i brought my little brother uh automatic
machine gun water guns they're pretty
[ __ ] incredible
and then he used him once i'm getting
into [ __ ] like that
bb guns real guns all that [ __ ] full
became a homeowner today he's like you
know
pulls this texas belt up oh i lived
there once and
now that i'm a whole [ __ ] out of here
protect my property
[Laughter]
yo marty's gonna grow yosemite sand
mustache soon i'm not
gonna say come in i'm stuck coming in
here to cowboy hat and [ __ ]
yo marty you're sick i'm gonna if i can
find a cowboy hat uh-huh
without trying to go buy one and it
comes the director on set
somebody was wearing one on saturday i
saw it was assistant director yeah
yeah yeah plaid shirt belt i remember it
all yeah yeah
there was two dudes with cowboy hats on
set this time and i was wondering did
they have a moment
like you got to be i'm the cowboy hat
guy
[ __ ] you the assistant director won
because i didn't see any more cowboy
besides him
he [ __ ] fired the other guy that
wears a cowboy hat how badass
justin my homie over here he hates
people that are taller than him
it's really funny because he's tall it's
pretty [ __ ] tall
and there's three dudes in my apartment
building that i think they play for ufc
but
they're over the elevator door
i got into the elevator door and went
are they got a doctor get in
yeah they have to go like that uh-huh
but i remember i stood in there i looked
down
like wait for real
one of them looked like a stick insect
the other two were
normal shaped dudes but like
six ten a seven foot and like maybe like
a seven two
but they were all had to do this they
were on their phones like that imagine
trying to fly on a [ __ ] plane like
that
[ __ ] this [ __ ] always ask me can
i get a house with like the window next
to it so i could be like
oysters i only fly delta because there's
no road next to something so i can put
my hands yeah
the last time we flew these angels
blessed us with the [ __ ] the regular
seats where
like i don't know there's more than a
half a [ __ ] foot of room between you
and the next seat
oh it's amazing people don't realize if
you're
above [ __ ] 511 your knees are in that
seat in front of you
it's like a goddamn cop car
damn cop car okay um we're rant city
rant city you ready uh-huh
last question and i think this is the
hardest one for sure all right
rosie's on her show yeah for real you
ready
would you rather be able to detect every
lie that you hear
or get away with every lie that you tell
um i don't i don't lie and i feel like i
catch lies oh same so but which one
would you want to be have a superpower
in one quest one candidate i would
rather want to be able to tell when
somebody's lying
same that's the only thing that matters
yeah like we're in a little situation
right now where we're trying to figure
out who the [ __ ] is lying hey
hey hey hey gentlemen gentlemen
i uh until further notice i don't want
to be getting upset
but some [ __ ] are lying in love
do you guys remember tekken
do you remember when martial law would
run up your knee up your chest do the
flip and land on you that's what i need
to do to that fool
and i'm getting upset and i don't want
to
[Music]
get upset about while you're getting
upset yeah yeah
but i i stone cold stunners
pedigrees big show choke slams all those
things
are crossing my mind thinking about this
guy because i'm like i haven't even met
you and i want to beat the
[ __ ] out of you but at the same time you
might not be telling the lion i'm the
mean guy
you're lying i think you're lying from
everything in my experience
you're a lyme [ __ ] you got real
mad when i went well what about this
well you would oh when you talk a little
too much and you got defensive quick
you're a lying piece of [ __ ] but it's
okay because i will sue
you no more punching people mm-hmm
that's fine we'll get on the phone with
you
and we'll be we'll be real calm and
we'll ask you a couple questions and we
both
have the same understanding coming out
of it just to know every time we get on
a call
conference call we know the goddamn
answers that we're asking you that
and by the time you go well that call
went
by the time you go well me and marty are
calling each other to go
this motherfucker's a [ __ ] liar like
there's
no hesitation there's one of us is
calling at the second there's a breath
after usually we're like texting during
the call too yup like oh this
motherfucker's piece of [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's crazy dude i i
uh
i don't think i'll ever get in a
situation like that again
and it wasn't that bad in the end it's
still a down payment on a [ __ ] house
yeah
for sure but it's like yeah
yeah okay you play the game yeah time to
play the game things are going well
triple h chalk it up a little bit but
not talking about yeah just
not not chalk it up but chalk up uh to
waiting
yeah oh wait the game is being good to
us right now so
yep no need to complain we're doing good
without it but [ __ ] you
so yeah be able to detect every lie you
hear honestly dude
i can i'm very good at picking up on
people right off the bat i assume
that it's a it process it goes through
the this over there
no just in life things go through the
this is a lie filter first
and then it has to be disproven into
truth most the time for me
i could just tell because i've sold so
much drugs so many drugs that i can tell
when people are bullshitting
yeah that's something i mean you could
tell when a [ __ ] hasn't
sold that 10 pack he's talking about or
can't get that pack at that price you
know what this 28 for the pack
um can you do a little cheaper nah i
would have said cheaper like in my hand
i would have told you cheaper but um nah
that's that's that's it man
and uh well you know i can get this a
little cheaper oh for real
let me get one because i would like to
get it cheaper
oh well you know he uh let me see if
he's got oh i thought you just had it
oh cause i'll buy five oh you can't get
it
you're a liar [ __ ] you that's how i i
[ __ ] hate [ __ ] at
fake weed shop mm-hmm
can i get a pack yeah and they leave
with a zip oh
i broke into the zip for you i broke
into this pack for you
you piece of [ __ ] now i got a breakdown
of the 15 ounces
i'm so glad i don't sell weed anymore
it's so [ __ ] awesome
can you scroll back down to our notes
i just got like a whole hot flash up
because i'm really nice i don't like get
mad at people
i like to keep it new yeah of course i
know i get mad that i get mad
same i get pissed off like i'm an
[ __ ] if i get genuinely upset at
somebody yeah
it's it's it's so hard for me to tell
you i'm upset
because you have to do something really
[ __ ] dumb uh-huh because i know i'm
stupid shelby yeah [ __ ] oh i had a i
i had two heated calls with somebody's
manager like that where they were
[ __ ] bullshitting me and they didn't
they got butt hurt when i checked them
on it it's
i know these stories but we'll keep it
at that uh
yeah [ __ ] off yeah please
yeah so suck a dick okay here we go
oh i forgot if you're driving please be
safe i always forget
i say it every time if you're driving
the car please be careful you heard my
car story earlier and marty [ __ ]
crashing and me falling asleep
be safe um this is a reoccurring topic i
guess
[ __ ] jeff bezos again we've talked
about that man three times two times at
least
yeah and now he went to space
i don't know i don't know right i didn't
know that the cowboy hat meme was that
guy i just thought it was a cowboy hat
guy my friend justin
[ __ ] hella internetti that full stays
and lives on the internet over there
jeff bezos went to [ __ ] space
and he's bald and his spaceships look
like a dildo and a dick
and everybody's making dr evil austin
powers means bro
why does he look so much like it looks
just like it looks like a flying dildo
behind him there's no way that he went
yo yo
great great aerodynamic shape
i'm sure that is what he said like
there has to be something looks like an
actual dick yeah i was gonna say like
isn't there a movie where they do this
can you please put in jeff bezos dr evil
when they compared it i went no come on
how
[ __ ] quick is the internet bro wow
how fast is the internet man i know look
i mean look at that picture dude that's
pretty [ __ ] spot-on they should have
just been
oh man by the way jeff bezos if you want
to sponsor this podcast
all right it's uh 80 racks
uh ad second a second yeah sorry it's 80
000
a second for 60 seconds it's 4.8 million
in ad read
um you will put your logo right yeah
it's fine
wow it's ready your logo yeah
i'll do that every for 4.8 million
dollars guys
and we won't expose your flying dick to
space i'll just be like yo
this brought to you by you know the king
of oz
the coolest [ __ ] in the day jeff
bezos
yep every time let me light up one of
these bezos the light of the bezos
i don't give a [ __ ] 4.8 million dollars
bro that's all i'm saying
so what the [ __ ] did he do in space just
like i don't think he really went to
space if a billionaire goes to space he
didn't record it
he didn't film himself inside yeah he
didn't go pro it [ __ ]
but what like just to go for the views
or you got you going on a mission
i got to be honest bro i don't know i
didn't look up enough because i don't
give a [ __ ]
but i do know that he is reoccurring in
this podcast because he's doing a bunch
of [ __ ] this year
randomly that we're like yo the richest
guy in the world is doing some dumb
[ __ ] but he got divorced and then
and then he was like yo i i need to go
to another planet because that [ __ ]
took [ __ ] 500 million dollars
oh wait billion i can't remember yeah
was also a commercial for rivie what's
rivion
oh that's why they put it there yeah so
we ask what
there you go yeah there it is uh is it
competing with tesla because he wants to
be
rich too like elon musk i mean it's a
bold statement going up in elon's
space that's like a canyonero
from simpson's canyon
damn it uh can we go back to the notes
[ __ ] jeff bezos god
we're at an hour and a half i gotta do
the tighten up
oh you ready what's up guys i want to
introduce our newest ad partner
this is keeps 95 percent of our audience
is men
95 of my dopa's yolo audience is men and
two out of three men experience hair
loss guys i
50 million dudes in america experience
hair loss
and i know some of you are like oh i'm
19. i don't give a [ __ ] my homie adam
was going bald at 16 and used to have
hair longer than mine
cut it one day didn't come back keeps is
a hair loss regimen for men this is a
company that
gives you every single thing you could
possibly need to regrow your hair and in
a lot of you were screaming at the
[ __ ] camera
you don't have that [ __ ] problem i
know i don't but this right here is hair
thickening gel
i'm not risking it i am over 30 years
old i know i don't look like it but
eventually i'm gonna have a problem with
this eventually we
all every dude out there is gonna
experience this so be like me guys and
take preventative steps to not losing
your hair and if like i said
if you're rocking that michael jordan
bald look and if you like it go for it
but i know there's a lot of homies out
there
that are losing their hand like yo i
don't [ __ ] with this
so if you are one of those dudes out
there that want to try it just go to
keeps.com
forward slash yola that's your first
month of treatment for free
the first full month is free the most
convenient thing about keeps right here
guys is you get an online consultation
with a doctor
and all your medicine is mailed to you
the entire regimen is mailed to you just
don't wait till you're like oh my god
it's gone
then you start trying it but if you are
it's gonna help it takes four to six
months for results out of any hair
regrowth company in the world has the
most five star ratings and when i talked
about this to my friends one of my
homies actually said he used this
and it worked and brandon from our team
oh that's right brandon used it too he
said it worked huh
he's [ __ ] 22 years old no here we go
before i go to you guys please remember
keeps.com forward slash yola that's
their whole first
month for free what's up guys this ad
read is brought to you by manscaped guys
it's summertime the world is open again
there's sports
everything is back it's summertime guys
it's nasty it's hot as [ __ ]
don't be nastier shave your [ __ ]
pubes the performance package is
available this month it comes with the
weed whacker and for some [ __ ] reason
has 9 000 rpms in it and i don't know
why
i guess i guess some people's hair out
there is thick as [ __ ] but
damn performance package comes with the
weed whacker it comes with ball
deodorant all right that's the first
time i've ever [ __ ] seen ball
deodorant in my life and yes we have the
ball cologne but ball deodorant that is
[ __ ] wild
if you think i'm [ __ ] around go to
the website it says ball deodorant on
the package
in general balls are just [ __ ] weird
anyway so don't have them being nasty
and [ __ ] hairy and gross i mean
if that's your thing go for it but not
manscaped
and to my right your left yes you're
reading it right that [ __ ] says
bald toner i have no idea what that
means guys i think we should all get
this package and we'll just keep each
other updated
my bottles are small and tight i have no
idea marty what the [ __ ] does ball toner
mean bro
it gets your balls shredded and i'll
tell you
buff ass balls package comes the weed
whacker the ball toner the ball
deodorant a travel bag which is actually
really [ __ ] nice
and this cool headband no i'm just
kidding it's a pair of [ __ ] underwear
but it's pretty [ __ ] cool
for the past couple weeks we've been
really talking about the lawnmower 4.0
but in the performance package it's
right [ __ ] here it comes with it guys
everything in one box so if you want to
check it out or check out anything else
they got
www.manscape.com forward slash yola
that's 20
off and free shipping so it's summertime
everything's opening up everything's
back get the lawnmower get the [ __ ]
landscape performance package get
everything
it's time to trim your balls two million
people can't be wrong just hit up
manscape like i said www.manscape.com
forward slash yolo 20
off free shipping everybody out there
this is coming out a week before
or a couple days before this airs we're
filming this
it's also two in the morning um kanye
west's new album was supposed to drop
so all i've been seeing is he didn't
drop it that's it
he didn't drop it it was supposed to be
released and it's gone okay
i told you yesterday i can't i'll just
say
i have a friend that he blesses the [ __ ]
out of me all the time he's a music
producer
[ __ ] you and i'm not looking at marty
i'm looking to just [ __ ] you
i have for this music producer he
produces music for people
and he always sends me like yo unrelease
this just check it out because he knows
i love
[ __ ] music right and he knows i'm
never gonna
yo i'm sending you this but please don't
send it to anybody [ __ ] that whatever i
hear from him it stays on my phone my
computer
done he sent me the whole kanye album
two days ago
he's like it's all released i go wait is
this the one that's coming out he goes
amazon smile wink facing the text i go
don't [ __ ] me click the link it
opened up brand new [ __ ] outwit are
you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
no way and you know obviously i'm like
yo you're the [ __ ] man
i appreciate you and then i went how did
you get this
he just a little bird okay
sick i don't know why i asked how
because he's not gonna tell me but i
just was curious
i'm like are you working with ghanaian
now [ __ ] yeah but obvious
obvious don't do that don't send me that
[ __ ] i don't get in trouble
i want to listen to it anyway i played
like three songs like yo
this is really the new how this is hard
and then
i woke up in the morning and i went to
play it in the
warehouse while i did orders i'm like yo
i'm gonna play the new kanye west
well i do orders right and then it went
these files have been deleted
in my whole dropbox file and then i get
on twitter and it goes kanye west
and it just says this full just deleted
his album and it said this fool didn't
release his album this got pushed back
and this is all the enemy go wait
oh it's real because my entire dropbox
files are gone
everything's gone that was like the
folder there was a i'm like you know no
way maybe they saw somebody else
active on it went kicked me the [ __ ] out
maybe i probably shouldn't have said
that on here huh no i don't give a [ __ ]
it's fine
i don't say no names but uh yeah i don't
know nobody
uh no i don't have no friends but anyway
he made me he's very excited
and then i [ __ ] up and she'll listen
to the whole thing right then and there
and i didn't and i only got to listen to
three songs
[Music]
she's um a piece of [ __ ] and didn't
download them and [ __ ] [ __ ] no
yeah no because then i just can't have
that a copy on my [ __ ]
yeah exactly just okay so i don't get
something in trouble but how
baller i remember just i played the
first one like yeah
yeah get to listen to this [ __ ] early
how cool he's done that a few times i
won't say what else but
he's done it a few times like yo you
know i love these fools thank you so
much that's a boss move just sounds like
everybody's
holy [ __ ] he always does it with no
context just in the middle of the day
boom you're welcome what
what unreleased you're a badass like i
i [ __ ] love this fool for that [ __ ]
you know what i'm talking about
[ __ ] he watches every [ __ ]
episode he watches all of our [ __ ]
you're the man um so yeah the new album
some [ __ ] happened to it but i
know all i know is it's real because i
win my dropbox is [ __ ] gone have you
do you listen to kanye's albums as they
come out like um so here it is ready
i listened to the first album my friend
anthony avila burned it for me
it was great album number two three
didn't really listen too because i
started getting into drugs and then
listen to albums as they came out
anymore so i was just i wasn't
on to it and i wasn't watching
mainstream tv i wasn't watching mtv or
this is you know i didn't listen to
radio but i know i liked kanye west even
though he was on the radio
and they started wearing the [ __ ]
weird glasses which we're seeing i had a
pair those are sitting i had locked down
there i used to have those glasses
before he started rocking like yo
people like these glasses now because
people just call me an idiot wearing
these things
i would swear because they were cool and
then around that time and started doing
like the
she had the best album of all time or
best music video when he started being
mean that taylor swift girl then
kanye west started going crazy and [ __ ]
i went oh man so i never listened to
another album
ever until last year because i told
rosie i said hey i have never listened
to all these albums she goes what the
[ __ ] yeah i haven't really either
bro that saint pablo when i really [ __ ]
with
the life of pablo i think it's called
it's great it's
i think it's great it's a [ __ ] just
an opinion but i went back and listened
to every single album
because i don't listen to the radio so i
missed all these artists you know i've
never listened a little way now in my
life
until last year until last year and i
went
boom listen em all went yeah i was
[ __ ] up
yeah those carters are monsters yeah
rosa what do you mean listen to cargo
what's the [ __ ] the carter she goes
little wayne's album
oh okay let's listen to it because i was
anti-radio my whole [ __ ] growing up
right
and um i remember ninth grade i had the
[ __ ] kanye
way and i had it in my [ __ ] head i'm
like yo this one crashed
and i was just thinking like that's a
good this is a good this is a good song
yeah
and then i let's do it forever and then
last year i listened to every album from
start to finish and went
wow i have missed out on so many
[ __ ] things you gotta if if kids out
there only know kanye from this stage of
his career you gotta go back to when he
was like
on the chappelle show and [ __ ] with
those freestyles my house
is so [ __ ] hard on that [ __ ] kanye
west dude
dave chappelle really [ __ ] brought
people up on that [ __ ] i mean they were
oh my god
kanye west wasn't even big yet at all
when that [ __ ] he wasn't
a rapper yet he was a producer he was a
producer but i don't even know if our
fans would realize that if you want to
go back and [ __ ] put yourself onto
something go back and listen to the
blueprint by jay-z
that [ __ ] came out during mid-911
that's where kanye broke into the world
as an executive producer of that album
with soul samples
bomb and it's one of the greatest
hip-hop albums of all time
i never listened to jay-z albums either
that's [ __ ] insane
still haven't i haven't done it but i'm
telling you like a lot of these
mainstream
all i was listening to was like dell and
[ __ ] living legends he's not
underground
you gotta i listen to people on the
radio remember that this whole mouse
wide open
i just didn't wasn't exposed to it my
mom didn't listen to the [ __ ] i didn't
listen to it nobody i knew listen to it
listen underground
something that people don't know like
jay-z is the first real independent
out of the trunk hip-hopper you know i i
know all the stories now that i'm an
adult but like yeah yeah
yeah this is a full album yeah i mean in
my lifetime volume one
all that [ __ ] bro please we have to sit
down
i totally will yeah that's the thing
like now it's like oh i can sit down and
appreciate it now that i'm not a little
[ __ ] about music anymore because you
used to be like oh you're on the radio
nope yeah like when they
this company used to work for us like oh
this new rapper he was k-dot his name's
kendrick lamar
yeah okay goes come we'll go chill hang
out like ah
i'm good bro i don't want to you know
drive out there three hours just like 10
years ago
[ __ ] this is 10 years ago right before
that up good kid mad city [ __ ] came out
and um you became a giant superstar no i
listened to
check the album out i got i listened to
when oh bro the concert was three days
ago
and i listened to the album after i went
who is this this is
[ __ ] bomb yeah he had been out for
like i had no idea in 15 years at that
point
yeah any of that music i listen might
say mac drain andre nicotine
[ __ ] too short and all the filthy
rich and all the base [ __ ] and sleepy ds
and all that [ __ ]
do you know you know who cormega is
cormega's a legendary deep new york city
rapper out of like queensbridge out of
naja's generation he was in the firm
never listened to a nazi album either oh
god damn
he was uh my mom was all west coast so
yeah you need to do all these things
like mob deep capone noriega
cormega all cut from that cloth gotcha
cormega featured the
jacka as a bonus trash as a bonus track
on his album
and everybody loves jack now that's how
i found out about him jack is one of the
hardest rap results that's what i'm
saying
that's a he's the only person i've ever
seen to do that you
just pick a random dude from the west
coast because he's that hard
yes to put on your album as a bonus
track one of my favorites
of all time is killer clip by the jacka
it's one of the hardest it's one of the
hardest courses ever if you just read
the lyrics like wow what a hard
simple but hard ass chorus it's so good
it's so [ __ ] good
i love that i love the jacka i met him
right before he [ __ ] passed away he
gave me his number
um i saw i was at a real quick story i
was at a
nations it's a burger spot in the bay
but i was the one in tracy
and i had i was with yuck mouth the
rapper for like two days
in the woods of washington at this event
young mouse mad coy's chill and um
i walk into nations i just drove back
from washington
just got back to the bay area stopped at
nations
got out i went no [ __ ] way the jack
is right there because i used to go to
the there's a place called so fresh set
out show
so fresh it's a store in santa cruz uh
jack and matt own it they're [ __ ]
awesome
they my sister shireen used to live in
santa cruz so what happens is
the catalyst has all the bay area
artists all the six shows that go to the
catalyst in santa cruz
the catalyst is uh right next to so
fresh and so fresh like the hip-hop
story they sell cds they sell clothes
all the dope [ __ ] right
so all the artists would come there and
do their in stores all their signings
before the concert
because maddie and jack dj dj
rex that's jack
dj rex that's jack he's part owner of so
fresh a lot of people don't know that dj
racks is a [ __ ]
white dude super cool super cool guy
and um i was sure they know shireen
because my sister used to work at the
record store
and they're right next to us the record
store that's the other one they buy cds
they know my sister well they smoke weed
so little brother coming up i got all
these albums
and like wait you you know like like you
know dilo
like yeah what's up he goes come here
and the first time i went there like wow
and i bought like 400 with these [ __ ]
cds
right and i was selling weed at the time
so i was like buying cds all the time
and
anyway i met jacka there
a little story about jacka i remember i
brought my stack of cds i only bought
cds
brought my stack anyway i know jack mad
they own the store so every time there's
an in-store they're like yo thomas just
come to the front
like that thomas and if there nobody
lets you in to say thomas is here
where's jack i've never waited in line
at any in store any signing any meet and
greet nothing because of them
i met so many [ __ ] artists in that
damn store
and i'm up there with my stack this is
the week after hustle just got out of
prison
so it is popping outside there's [ __ ]
hella fools
and i have a stack of cds like that and
the jack is there and he has this double
cup i'm like
oh he's drinking lean and he's doing
this [ __ ] oh he
[ __ ] up and i thought
cool [ __ ] it get [ __ ] up yep but you
have a show
how are you going to wake up i thought i
could think like how are you going to
wake up and like perform
i wasn't i was like yeah get [ __ ] up
because i'm about to be [ __ ] up to not
have lean but
i'm going to get drunk right now and go
to the show and um
i'm just i give my cd goes damn before
we go oh damn fool you got this one
yeah i got them all it's like i bought
it here and jax looks at me
looks like this is our homie thomas
right here he's matt young but like he
he gots all your [ __ ] so i'm talking to
jack and he's like
yo he's all [ __ ] up but i'm like just
a [ __ ] jack
in front of me oh my god i'm talking to
him
and jack is i'm like he's uh let me get
that let me start signing all my cds
oh [ __ ] yes he starts signing my cds
[ __ ] up
he's like doing this [ __ ] signing my cds
i'm like this is the best experience i
could ask for
[ __ ] yeah and then hustle's right there
and i'm like
hey by the way man i'm a big [ __ ] fan
so i'm like you know i was like 15
16 at the time like oh well big fan
maybe 17
and uh as i do the next person in line
like kind of bumps me out of the in
front of jackass i'm like no uh
[ __ ] those are my cds but i'm in full
conversation mode with hustle and talk
about this album he did
demolition man with jack and he goes
damn you [ __ ] on that [ __ ] huh i'm
like
so demolition man blah blah blah and it
turns out hd outfitters my friend
charles that helped me start push trees
and all this [ __ ] was the guy doing all
the mixtapes for them for demolition man
this all came full circle it was crazy
anyway i'm talking to hustling deep in
conversation i look back and jack is
gone
and he's got his back against the wall
like four feet away he's trying to eat
this piece of pizza as hard as he can
he's like
i'm like wow he's [ __ ] up
also i do not want pizza fingers on my
cds i know you're on the cds but these
are my cds i don't want
them greased up like he was eating
dripping-ass pizza i'm like
that's hilarious i'm gonna i'm gonna
take these out before he comes back
because i want
signatures i want his autograph on all
he signed like
four out of like 12 cds but still i
still got the tear gas bam
two thomas or something like on it
and um anyway i had all his albums right
flashback back to nations i see him in
the hamburger spot
i'm like oh [ __ ] no way and this is why
i'm doing dope as yolosh i'm doing all
this [ __ ] this is like
six years ago seven i'm like no [ __ ]
way and i
walk to get my food and i'm and he walks
by me
and i don't say nothing and as i'm
walking back i'm like
and he looks at me and goes what's up
man you could tell i was like
oh [ __ ] no he could see it in my eyes
even though i wasn't like showing i was
just like that
what's up man like guys we both went to
go get napkins i was like
yeah yeah he goes what's up man like
what's up jacka i'm like yo i'm a big
ass fan he's like
oh cool for you smell like [ __ ] fire
oh yeah i just took a long ass road trip
i've been smoking all night where are
you coming from like
from up in the [ __ ] thing i was like
i was actually with [ __ ]
yuck molly goes you with yuck mouth
yeah and i said another person that i
was with
i'll leave it at that he goes
why were you with them nice looking kid
with gangster rappers
i go oh i do this [ __ ] i direct like
little videos he goes
oh you've been doing blah blah blah i
showed him my [ __ ] he goes no [ __ ]
all right all right i had like like 250
000 probably at the time but
it's like for you you make these videos
i'm like jagger's got my phone in his
hand he's going through my videos this
is [ __ ] insane
and he goes take my number down and i'm
like all right cool
and he's like yeah he's give me your
phone he puts his number my phone
i'm like what the [ __ ] he said shoot me
a text
and i'll save your number i'm like okay
thank you jacob i walk out i'm like
the [ __ ] jack is inside and i tell
her the whole thing like
the [ __ ] jacket just gave me his
number and i texted him like yo it's
thomas thank you so much bro
hit me up whenever and he hit me back
right away he's like yo i'm actually
driving through merced right now you
from a set right i'm like
yeah he's like i'm going through merced
right now
[ __ ] out of here he's like locked in
oh my god got killed three weeks later
damn
yeah and i had an idea for this
huge music like long scripted music
video i had it all written out
and it was about this gangster rapper
blah blah blah blah blah blah all this
[ __ ] right
i'm like who would fit this world like
this role good
i was like jacka he's the only one
that's a lyricist but a gangster rapper
that i knew
and the whole thing was at the end you
get pop he gets popped and like i'm so
[ __ ] glad i didn't pitch that bro
how sad was that like oh yeah at the end
i died [ __ ] you fool
but no but it's like some art [ __ ] bro
you gotta think it because the way i was
thinking about filming it
i won't say what it is now i told
somebody this that owns a very big
record label
they [ __ ] did my idea hmm
maybe they didn't steal it maybe because
i asked him like yo so what the [ __ ] bro
i told you my whole [ __ ] you guys just
do oh no bro that was an outside team we
didn't even have nothing to do with that
mic
it was shot for shot [ __ ] okay
done
i was so pissed i won't even say who it
was it's a [ __ ] major artist though
and my homies managed them and they're
all i was [ __ ] so
mad because i love the artist that did
the music video so i'm watching my music
video
with two artists i listened to and i
bought that album like no
[ __ ] waste i want to hear the song
i'll tell you after when i hear the song
i'm just like
[ __ ] man i just get irritated but still
it's cool to see my [ __ ] idea i've
got a major music video
like it can be done it could be done
anyway jacka that's my jacket story
damn i didn't know any of that yeah i
love that fool i got every album up till
i think
he did the compilation one money shark i
think it was called
with underneath continued collaboration
and that's why i stopped going to santa
cruz buying cd so much
that was it i just really stopped buying
cds at that point because i wasn't going
to santa cruz that's the only reason why
um but yeah that's my jacket story
[ __ ] ridiculous
anyway hustle's cool now and he's a fan
of my [ __ ] i saw him at a cannabis club
he's like yeah you make those sick ass
videos
get the [ __ ] out of here because i like
your [ __ ] man i follow you i'm glad i
looked i'm like yo he does follow me
i didn't even know it's like three years
ago five years ago bro i was
at an in-store waiting for you to
[ __ ] sign my
uh hustling since the 80s cd now you're
like y'all like your [ __ ] like
no way it was a good like a surreal
moment for me man that's some deep
[ __ ] west coast hip-hop
[ __ ] cool right there yeah it was very
cool
very cool also i mean i was at a
a norms and a celski you know celski
um he's a rapper from the bay and i walk
in i'm like yo that is
[ __ ] celsius right there holy [ __ ] i
didn't say nothing but i sat down he's
like
hey yo i like your [ __ ] i see your video
i'm like oh
[ __ ] way bro did he just say that
[ __ ] to me and i sat down the whole
night was great
it was [ __ ] amazing bro i just want
to blow them
or join with them i bet half these
rappers are watching your [ __ ] i mean i
just thought like rappers i grew up like
wow that's kind of [ __ ] having their
albums and [ __ ]
you watch my [ __ ] that's weird
nice yeah that's like the ultimate
win for me i was so hyped somebody that
you wrote around really listening to and
you're all geeked out about it as a kid
is a fan of your still still stoked
about it it was just one of those fan
moments where i was like no way bro
that's the ultimate fan moment in my
life
thank you how cool one day brett favre
oh you know what i bought some of your
weed in the store like [ __ ] you
can you sign my wee jar please take a
picture with me please
and apologize i got a picture with brett
favre i just leave it at that
you'd be good even make you whole
one day man one day
one day brett favre will be sitting in
the same room
i won't be sweating like this maybe i
will be i don't [ __ ] know
probably i don't know rage
he'll definitely be sweating like this
[ __ ] it
would you present him with the
opportunity to write his wrongs
i'm still such a i have like five brett
favre statues in my shell
at my house right now still i'm gonna go
active
oh yeah um why we get on there i have no
idea but here we go
let's get out of that damn that's a long
story [ __ ]
i'm all sweating here we go
real quick i just want to touch on this
i'm sweating to death out here it's
2 am it's 2 in the morning it's hot yeah
some [ __ ]
yeah sorry guys here we go real quick
just touch on this push trees cannabis
uh i released a strain because
i didn't have the time or manpower to do
a whole
lineup of strains so i dropped it with
this company i dropped one strain
we sold out in like three hours it was
[ __ ] amazing we sold the [ __ ] out
and then i went back to him like so
when's the next batch and they go uh
three months no don't tell me you guys
aren't as
honest they're supposed to be on a cycle
where they're harvesting every week or
every two weeks
by the way like if you know like above a
bigger farm wait are you asking me to
find
you a farm you're a farm
that's insane so i cut the contract
right then and there i went up you guys
i'm a step away so i stepped away guys
and then you know you guys ask in the
comments where's the weed at where's the
push tree's weed at
i just haven't found anything any deal
that i
want to do because i have to be hands-on
i have to pick everything
i have to [ __ ] do quality checks i
have to go in and make sure each
grower's not a piece of [ __ ] i have to
go in and make sure everything's perfect
i gotta smoke it i gotta make sure when
they're trimming when they're drying
i have to do everything but actually
touch it
i'm gonna go in there and make sure
everything's good get on the cycle get
on with people i trust
and make it work but it's going to take
a while the reason i'm bringing that up
i might have found that working on it
right now
so if it does work there will be a push
trees
delivery service attached to push trees
cannabis co
and we will literally drop off weed in a
push trees [ __ ] bag
all right so push trees cannabis company
we're working on a little deal right now
so if it goes through
push trees will be on every shelf in
california
every legal shelf in california hey
i didn't think you're gonna do that
right now that scared me
um hash pens edibles
solvent lists every every variation of
weed every single thing you've ever seen
on our page
our channel will just make it push trees
now
and that's it and that's how it's gonna
[ __ ] go
it seems like an inevitable stop in your
car i mean you'll know it's gonna be
fire
i would never allow anybody to put
[ __ ] in there i'd rather not do the
deal like i have
for two [ __ ] years yeah i would you
would have did you would have done a
deal two years ago
i had a deal with the biggest [ __ ]
dude in california you know ever he owns
a piece of
let's leave it at that he is the by far
the biggest cannabis
mole goal in california and
possibly this in the united states
maybe not maybe like two or three top
two or three but no matter what
it's like 60 000 lighter
across all the grows and it's like that
if you know about weed
that doesn't even sound real something
i'm lying it's [ __ ] real
i will guarantee you that all these
buildings in california you think are
shirt factories and [ __ ]
oh no they're growing wheat the first
time i ever saw an illegal
operation that was unreal was in la
i won't say where i thought it was a
shirt factory
because it said it was a sugar factory
shirts and red shirts
yeah i walked in it was a
state-of-the-art grow in there
mm-hmm with like fake stuff in the
windows to make it look like it was
a real piss pictures of it was crazy i
was
you [ __ ] yeah like thank you for
bringing me here this is sick
get me out of here as soon as i got in
there went oh no no no all these fools
are staring at me
uh i don't like this let me get the [ __ ]
out of here and when i was walking down
the hallway i got the feeling on the
back of my neck that
someone was i know vibes
and i got to feel in the back of my neck
i need to get the [ __ ] out of here i'm
done
i'm out and then they got robbed at
gunpoint though two nights later
randomly and the security guards end up
being in on it
so i did have that feeling for a reason
god damn yeah i felt like
nah something the [ __ ] something's wrong
here i need to get the [ __ ] out
that door closed i don't know my way out
of here
but anyway pusher's cannabis goal was
will be legal
and none of those vibes would be a bunch
of britneys and
kenneth's okay working
facilities and marios all right
there'll be a lot of marios for sure i
met a grower uh shout out to jeff uh
true cannabis uh i've never met a
mexican dude named jethro
but mexican named jethro was pretty
[ __ ] awesome yeah yeah
um what are we at like 140 like 202 no
we're not
yeah marty no we're not
oh my god sorry
it's been a while okay ready see this
joint
how much i got in there 10 minutes 12.
it's like a regular person's joint
all right ready i have a story mattel
i'm knocking it out by the time this
joint's done
all right concise and you know what's
precise you know what's really crazy
this story has jacket in it for no
reason
i didn't even plan that you guys heard a
lot about me selling weed as a pizza guy
me and ed's right story time let's go
uninterrupted i
eye contact let's go marty you're right
here oh look at this camera
story time you ready go you've heard
this on story time before but for all
the fans
all the new fans here we go in depth
story time how i quit my pizza job
this is a a lot better than how i quit
mcdonald's let me tell you that
so you guys are pretty [ __ ] good it
was i think about it often a lot of
people
always tell me starting my job at
mcdonald's a day
i get a lot i've probably gotten like
seven dms of that exact wording
and like 50 of that meta sound to
mcdonald's is like the everlasting
gobstopper
i know [ __ ]
it's the same [ __ ] sound when you
cook in the mcdonald's anyway
dancing i just turned a 60 minute story
if i would keep going here we go ready
go
joint i worked at meanness for over four
years
i sold weed to my manager's mom i got my
manager high
we hung out we smoke weed we get [ __ ]
up we do stuff
he's my friend i thought um here we go
ready go
i have never missed a day of work except
once when i threw him back out
and i called half a day ahead you're
supposed to have five hours
if you caught within five hours of your
shift
i mean if you call with five hours left
before you shift you don't get penalized
like a missed day
no show because somebody has to cover
for you so technically
five hours is all the time you need i've
never taken a day off
i've been late like four [ __ ] times
and one time i woke up black out drunk
still
and made it to work still came into work
throwing up outside
i went to the jacket show i said i'm
going to the jack show i went
[ __ ] alone that's how much i wanted
to go the show
i went by myself and one of the first
times i went to 21 and up section
by myself i met jay stalin
he's little i didn't think he was gonna
be so little but i'm like yo jay stalin
that's my [ __ ] jason i was sick
and anyway i was uh in this 21 and over
section
it's 11 10 no it's nine o'clock at night
barely
jack is not even on stage yet i text my
boss
john i'm not gonna be able to make my
shift tomorrow at 10. i now have 13
hours before my shift
never [ __ ] called in ever one time
ever except
one day when i threw my back out like i
said
call my friend text my friend john
manager
john i'm not gonna be able to make it uh
i'm in santa cruz at a concert and i'm
uh
i'm drinking dude and i think i'm just
gonna just take a day off tomorrow
we have two other people that can cover
me and i text them already
you ready um they never text me back
so at like nine o'clock i text john well
who's covering you
in my head i'm like [ __ ] that's your
job you're the manager
no one's ever asked that question but
now it's me [ __ ] you
i go um i text so-and-so and the other
guy
and they didn't answer yet he goes well
so you're showing up tomorrow go no no
i'm telling you now like i'm not going
to show up
i'm getting [ __ ] up i'm shit-faced
drunk i'm gonna
i'm gonna show in santa cruz because uh
i don't know what to tell you man but
you should be here at 10 in the morning
or you're gonna be in no show i go john
i'm not [ __ ] coming bro i'm telling
you with 13 hours advance
i was getting upset texting him i'm not
[ __ ] coming
what are you talking about like kind of
like
[ __ ] you know that's the way i was
coming like [ __ ] you what are you doing
to me right now
what if i saw your mom weed you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you 13 hours i go john it's five
hours our policy it's 13 hours advance
he goes bro
if you don't have anybody to cover you
five hours means nothing that is not the
policy john
what are you talking about i've been
working here for four you know i gave
him the whole thing
like what are you doing like all right
stop i stopped texting him
and he text me like six times in a row
so you're not coming so you're just
gonna not show are you quitting
is this you quitting are you not coming
tomorrow do you not work here
[ __ ] [ __ ] send me [ __ ] ass text and i
went
i threw my [ __ ] phone off like [ __ ]
face drunk [ __ ] this
watching enemy jacket came out and he
got mad at the
the crowd because they didn't know the
lyrics to one song i'm over here
screaming the [ __ ] lyrics from the
top
and i was like yeah [ __ ] gekks you used
to do [ __ ] like
why you fools in the front on all my
[ __ ] then why are you in the [ __ ]
front
good point why the [ __ ] you in the front
you're not even like a
move let the other fools that are
screaming their heart out come in the
front
anyway i remember that night and i'm
[ __ ] up
and it's about 11
30 and i'm [ __ ] up
i turned my phone back on and i got like
seven more messages
of i just questioned my question mark
question mark all right so
are you not working here anymore [ __ ]
like that
so here we go guys ready go it's about 1
30 in the morning i don't text him back
so i'm pissed
i work at nine
i'm supposed to work at n ten supposed
to work at ten i have a
long time before i have to [ __ ] be
there
so it's about one thirty the show
stopped like eleven
i don't know twelve it's like one thirty
i'm not [ __ ] shit-faced anymore
but i'm definitely not sober and it's a
bad decision but i went
i'm gonna wait it out sober up and drive
home
so i waited till like three o'clock
wasn't drunk anymore i went i'm driving
home
and i text john at like three in the
morning
no no no i waited i got home and texted
him i made it home
power smoked cigarettes and joints and
blunts i just smoked sig still
power smoked the [ __ ] out of them got
home fell asleep on my couch
jeebus my roommate at the time works at
me and ed's also
right
i'm texting my friend deuce what's going
on and jeeps
i text him like what happened with john
right it takes my half of the manager
and i text john at six like in the
morning right the sun come up so i
wouldn't be a weirdo and text him in the
middle of the night right
i text him um dude i'm not coming in
i don't know what you want me to do hold
up you just text me if you don't show up
you're a no-show i don't know if you
work here anymore
just like that like i'm gonna fight for
a no-show once
you're supposed to get three why is this
paul why is he being weird with me
it made me more mad because i know the
policy i [ __ ] work every day i've
been working for four years
[ __ ] or five-star pizza restaurant we
had we're rated five
stars the merced mayonnaise how wild
and uh not on yelp [ __ ] like
through like the businesses we were
raided five-star restaurant and we were
a pizza place
anyway um i'm already home but i'm
telling him
i just want to see his [ __ ] reaction
see how this little [ __ ] is gonna act
and he
said that to me so i
i just i told john i don't know what to
tell you man i'm not home
blah blah 20 minutes later i text him
so you're being a jerk so i'm on the way
back uh we'll be there
[ __ ] it i'm gonna be late like i'm
probably gonna be late but i'll drive
back
okay i'll be there [ __ ] i didn't know he
had text jeebus to cover my shift
so my roommate had to get up and go
cover my shift anyway it's remember it's
like
seven something in the morning i'm half
asleep i has
just went to sleep a couple hours ago
drank
thought i was getting [ __ ] up for the
night and ended up having to sober
myself up what a [ __ ] by myself
remember that and bring nobody with me
so i'm laying there and i text deuce i
text jeez i can't remember who i
preached i think it takes them both
no i think it was deuce but i text
hella laughing face like john's a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
because i had already been texting
what's going on but john's acting like a
little [ __ ]
[ __ ] ah he thinks i'm [ __ ] driving
back i'm on my couch
and i accidentally text that to my boss
[Music]
in the mix-up of tax party god damn
i didn't noticed about three minutes
later when i went jam this wasn't
texting me back yet i went
did i not erase the text or what
i checked oh [ __ ] everyone's on the
couch like kick my feet [ __ ]
oh you pieces [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you had that sound board ready
marty that was the move of the year it's
july
and you [ __ ] beat the whole year
right now with that bye [ __ ] despise
you right now yeah oh my god
don't do that to me don't do that i
scared the [ __ ] out bro
my whole spine just tensed up i thought
i really heard a gunshot coming in here
marty oh my god i mean it's on film you
can see my genuine [ __ ]
stomach drop right now
oh marty you [ __ ] that scared me
this gave me bad
[Music]
so you texted the damn it marty [ __ ]
the gunshots were too much it scared me
i'm all sweating i'm sweating on my arms
i text him all that [ __ ] by accident
realize i do
and i don't text him anymore that's it
i go back to sleep and i wake i wake up
at like 10
50 almost 11 o'clock and i text john so
do you want me to come in
i just got back like you i had my day
off and now i'm
you know i'm giving him the [ __ ]
thing pretending i didn't text him the
whole thing about him
just like just i [ __ ] went over that
speed bump right so am i just coming in
yeah i'm just like i'm coming in said
you like ruined my whole [ __ ] night
bro like he was texting me and like
now you're not texting me and i text him
so question mark a question mark uh
text like four times
you know not crazy like i'm back ball
[ __ ] you dick question mark
question mark not a lot that's going to
come in handy later so [ __ ] remember
that [ __ ]
i barely text him four times back he
texts 38 times without me responding
remember
we're going paragraph paragraph
paragraph paragraph back to each other
while i was at the concert too like dude
what are you talking about the policy
like why are you acting like this what
are you doing like i'm literally [ __ ]
shitfaced bro that's why i'm calling you
now i'm texting you now before what the
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] dick anyway i
call because he stopped texting so i
call me and ends like so john
hangs up what a [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i call back like yo don't hang up for
what are you doing
i know you're the only one there because
the driver is the only guy that makes
pieces and drives that's my position
stupid
i know you're there [ __ ] and he goes
what do you want bro
dude what are you talking about i drove
back do you want me to come in or not
i don't know what you're talking about
man i already had someone feel your
position your no call no show and you
hung up on me
jesus christ i know that all right
cool i am a logical person
i was selling halloween i didn't need
the job i only had the jobs i could have
a paycheck and
not look like i was selling a weed
get paid wow they paid for my gas and
gave me like 200
in tips they gave you a platform yes a
platform while i was selling weed out
their time yeah
yeah and i made free [ __ ] pizzas you
were getting paid to sell weed
while getting paid to sell wheat yeah
i'm getting paid to drive around
and then sell eat this is out i'm almost
done with the story we did pretty
[ __ ] good
here we go i go oh okay he hung up on me
all right cool i rushed to my room and i
neatly folded every
me and ed's thing i've ever had i put
them all right there
put my name tags and i was like [ __ ]
this put in my seat i started driving to
my
thing i'm like what am i going to say to
this folks i was like i'm quitting right
now
[ __ ] you and i was his opener
i opened from six from 10 to six
i don't know why are you so quick to
[ __ ] on me i don't [ __ ] understand it
i don't i don't
[ __ ] get it i don't understand we
were all good
good good friends we were all homies
friend like waiting the movie waiting
with ryan reynolds
and justin long he was ryan reynolds i
was just in law like
we're friends [ __ ] that's really
pissed me off dude
so i'm pulling up like imagining
for everybody in the car at home i'm
just like
imagine punching him [ __ ] you all right
so just in case you're in the car going
what is this
dead silence so i just explained that
marty
i'm so [ __ ] burnt here we go i walk
in
and i didn't know jesus had covered the
shift so i saw jesus car went
no my roommate's covering the [ __ ]
shift
no he saw me asleep on the couch when he
left the house
even though he knows i was texting him
even though he's like
if i'm covering your [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't
know
i didn't know i didn't know so
i open the door i open the door like you
open doors in gta
all abrupt open the door i walk up and
there's a customer with him like
[ __ ] i'm a customer service guy to the
max i am not going to give this customer
a shitty experience even though i don't
work here anymore yeah
so i walk in and jeebus like that
getting the big ass
wooden uh grabber for the pizza the
slider
he's like huh i can see him like at
first he smiles and goes
like what's that huh you look matt close
in your hand
oh i could see him break it down
in his while i was walking you see him
assessing the situation
and i just walk up and there's a
customer and john's looking at me like
he's with the customer so you still talk
imagine that he's like look he's talking
the customer he goes like that
while still talking to the customer
looking at me like yeah sir so what do
you want
you know imagine that in your head
and i walked to the bar and i'm like
[ __ ] he's with somebody so i grab my
stuff he's look at me i go
hey right here i quit i'm out i quit
and i walked out and i kept my pizza
sign so i could sell weed with it
nice but uh it was very anticlimactic
not done i think i would tell the story
like that [ __ ] off
you think that's my my ending not over
i went like that quit i'm done jeep is
like that
jaw dropped in the back get the [ __ ] out
i got jeebus and deuce and all my
friends at the job there i was the first
one to get a job there i'm like yo you
should hire my friend jeeps
hi my friend deuce hey how about a
friend like and we did we all it was a
time where it was just us to be on the
ship
that's the best yeah i just saw weed
both of them they're my friends from
high school
we just ran a five-star restaurant i got
nothing bomb reviews got mad tits made
the coolest pizzas and left
so i know john i remember john's face
like that
like he was like oh my god [ __ ] i [ __ ]
up i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up
um his face damn everything's a
reference to me
do you remember was it varsity blues
come on let's go let's go let's go
was it varsity blues the coach is a
piece of [ __ ] justin
varsity blues the coaches and pieces
[ __ ] is that what michael scott watches
the
15 minutes of movies right today we
watch 30 minutes of varsity blues again
in the office oh you're a bad bearded
man you don't remember
anyway okay i think it's varsity blues
where the coach is with bill yeah it is
varsity boots with the butt with the
with the coach and like yo billy bob
yep anyway uh remember when he's like
realizes at the end like come on tima he
realizes he lost him
he's like get out there come on let's go
let's go let's go let's go
when he's trying to crawl him back up
that was john's eyes like
[ __ ] a lot that's it
where's my weed because in my mind i'm
like you just got
cut off you can never buy weed for me
again
[ __ ] you i leave funnest day ever
i'm not done you think i'm done [ __ ] no
that's terrible [ __ ] varsity bruce
reference that's not the end
i go home everything's funny jesus comes
back i tell him i tell dude she's like
[ __ ]
quit [ __ ] i quit and i
tell him like no [ __ ] way my friend
justin that worked there
um it was just a weird
fun day i go to get my last check
here's where the fun starts this is
where the fun starts real quick i'ma
tighten it up marty
you have to drive all the way back home
to irvine irvine
don't do it don't do it here we go here
we go
so i go to get my check because i'm like
nah nah
i'm getting my check [ __ ] it i want that
give me that 300 bucks give me it [ __ ]
you
even though i just made 300 in this ass
zip i'm selling me at the time
i want that check cause [ __ ] you yeah so
it's like where's your sign i walked in
and we supposed to like do the meeting
sign the thing you quit you're not fired
that way they don't have to pay you
whatever he's like you quit
i thought i'm sorry i'll quit the normal
when you quit paper you sign it i'm like
cool
done i'm out thank you for my check sign
for my check i'm out first thing i walk
in he's at the bar waiting
for me the bar part of the restaurant
and i walk in he's like where's your
sign at
i go you mean the one on the wall
he says no i'm missing a sign i go ask
the other driver so i don't have your
sign is it my trunk
your sign the [ __ ] i kept that [ __ ]
anyway um deuce actually ended up using
it for his [ __ ] dick my friend deuce
he was still working there after
and used it one time i never got my
[ __ ] sign back deuce you [ __ ]
um so i walk in where's the sign
goes through the whole ordeal i sit down
i start signing the paperwork
i'm not even saying [ __ ] and then i sign
the first paper and i look at him and go
this is stupid you know that right he
goes i don't know man you didn't show up
so
like you quit so you just don't want to
work here you don't want you're not a
team player
[ __ ] you that's what i said first thing
i saw [ __ ] you because we're friends but
now
man slows off [ __ ] you i gave you
advance i'd said it to him person like i
gave you advance
for some reason you got mad at me said
you're gonna let me not work here
anymore
i'm supposed to get three this is my
first one ever in four years
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i could see
it on his face like the varsity blues
coach again like
i know if i say sorry you'll come work
here all i wanted to him go i'm [ __ ]
so sorry
i'm a dick all this [ __ ] and i would've
went give me my shirt back
because i love i loved work i [ __ ]
loved that place it was so
fun i loved working there
i was like yeah give my [ __ ] back that's
fine that's all i want to hear what the
[ __ ] wrong with you bro
why am i you know that's all i wanted to
hear and i could see what he wanted to
say
he wanted to say it so bad and i'm
waiting for him to say he didn't say it
well all right i started signing the
second paper
he doesn't know that like to give a [ __ ]
don't give a [ __ ] in my brain it's so
strong
i don't think he realized it and as i'm
signing it
and i'm like so like you know you [ __ ]
this up right like
i they're gonna quit eventually like
this is done like you [ __ ] this up all
right
and he's just sitting there with a beer
on [ __ ] on the clock with a beer i'm
like
okay bro like we don't give a [ __ ] but
now that you're firing me like
you know you get fired for that right
[ __ ] you you're firing me basically but
anyway
after that he goes and gives me another
paper he hasn't given my check yet guys
he's not giving me my [ __ ] check
i signed that i quit paper right during
the whole [ __ ] you you're a [ __ ] i'll
eat a dick
your mom's got off all that [ __ ] right
um
because i sold it to him he gave it to
his mom it's not like i cut his mom off
i would never cut off some nice lady i
cut him up [ __ ] him
and um she bought my shake which was so
bomb
i didn't want it the shake at the end of
the pack she would pout she would buy it
i just got hooked her up but still
she would buy the [ __ ] that was just
going bad and um
underneath that other paper i move it i
go why is there another paper and he
goes oh yeah
so this one is the harassment suit that
i'm following against you
your face yep your face right there
dad looked me in the eye and goes this
is for the harassment suit and i go
all right yeah where's my check i was
like i thought he was [ __ ] with me
he's been accused of sexual harassment
like seven times he worked there it's
like a joke
like he makes stupid [ __ ] sexual
jokes all day every day
all day every day and he hires pretty
girls so he's always making stupid jokes
but everyone laughs it's [ __ ]
hilarious
except for the ones that have dignity
for themselves and they go
uh i'm [ __ ] following a lawsuit and
he's been he's beat all seven
like all seven of them so he's putting a
lost section he's putting a suit
a harassment suit on me made me go are
you
[ __ ] serious because it was the
running joke like damn y'all you're
gonna catch another suit [ __ ]
he got one there with me on shift once
and then he even stayed in bed anyway
i go john are you [ __ ] serious i was
mad
and he goes thomas you kept texting me i
would not respond and you would not stop
texting me
when i stopped responding to you i go
john
if you text me 38 times i text you like
39.
so john we were having a full long
conversation he's like i have over 30
text messages from you like john i have
30 texts that's just from you too
you [ __ ] and i'm trying to
explain to him like
before it's a conversation now that
you're mad now it's harassment that i
was responding
can i ever sue you for harassment too
then you text me 40 times when my
phone's off
can i and i was just sitting there like
no way there's no way this [ __ ]
my friend is trying to get me in a suit
i'm like there's no way he's trying to
[ __ ] sue me for harassment
and he was dead serious i had all the
[ __ ] filled out my name what happened
the times
everything and i go john you know i'm
not signing that right
i hope you listen to this john you know
i'm not signing that right
anyway john hernandez of merced
california [ __ ] you for anybody out
there uh your dick
anyway um so you know i'm suing i'm not
gonna sign this
bull she goes thomas you're not getting
the [ __ ] check unless you're signing
i go john
[ __ ] the check then i am not signing
this
[ __ ] it was thomas you're signing it
or i'm going to sue you i know all right
john look at me do you want to tear it
up do you want me to tear it up
because i'm not signing this you know
i'm not [ __ ] signing this look at my
face you know me
sorry [ __ ] you but the way he was saying
it was very like i don't know what to
tell you man
like very boss like yeah yeah this is
what happened you kept texting me you
would not stop so this is what's going
on beer in here
i'm like uh no i told him the whole
thing like uh do you want me to rip it
up or you
what i just said and he goes you're
really not signing this huh
john you want to throw it in that trash
can right
because i'm not signing this [ __ ] and he
goes here's your [ __ ] check bro he
threw it in the trash though
yeah good for you and i went you should
be very ashamed of yourself right now
bro
that was some [ __ ] [ __ ] and i as i said
[ __ ] [ __ ] he went holy [ __ ] it's like a
spell went
yo thomas what happened that's like he
woke up and went
what did i just do i went that was some
you're [ __ ] lame
as i walked out with my check like
you're [ __ ] whack
as hell opening like the ripping the
sides of my check
you're a [ __ ] and i'm like you're a
bit that was [ __ ]
and as i said i could see his face like
come back he was like yo i'm so [ __ ]
sorry i'm so [ __ ] sorry and he didn't
say anything
and i walked out and quit and then the
next time i came in i was buying pizza
and i was like yo what's up man how are
you doing it's like oh
what's up man how's everything going so
i didn't say anything like oh i see the
two stars are gone now you're
a three star i guess because we always
kept our stars away
[Music]
because deuce had quit by then too
jeebus was about to quit
our friend justin that was the assistant
manager our friend that deuce lived
with that smoked weed he quit already
i'm just like oh my god this place is
going down
[ __ ] here he's like uh yeah so how
you been i'm like i'm good man
can i get this this this this and i sat
there watching like yeah don't spit my
[ __ ]
i know where to sit i know where to sit
to see you i worked here
and that is how i quit me and ends
that's the whole story nice
yeah then how long did you still ride
around decide on no dudes [ __ ]
borrowed it like three [ __ ] four
weeks into me quitting
so i never got it back i think john was
like yo i know thomas has to get it back
i think that's probably what happened he
worked there he's really off all right
we'll get it back
because maybe john saw me riding around
small little town dropping sacks off
[ __ ] you
um but yeah that's how i quit me and
adds man and i went back
and john eventually got fired for sexual
harassment
one of them stuck this time he got uh he
got fired like
two years later he wasn't really a creep
at all it was just he makes
funny jazz jokes i mean like but it was
to the wrong person
yeah that's it feel you're not supposed
to run
businesses if you're not contain i get
it a hundred percent
yeah it's supposed to but also we have
nine people working there
five are my actual friends yeah yeah and
john's the one saying sexual [ __ ] we're
just talking about stupid the new south
park episodes yeah
that's really all we're talking about
and then john's over there saying like
oh blah blah blah i'm like ah i wouldn't
have said that bro maybe at a bar
when you already bought her a drink but
maybe not at work on her first date
that's how i quit me and ed's and we're
at what 2 12 2 30.
no we're not no we're not marty that
didn't take 28 minutes
your sense of time gets a little hazy i
think is it really
yeah i mean [ __ ] we're only talking
about a couple minutes different
oh you're not [ __ ] with me it's three
in the morning
okay 2 30. marty there's no way bro
it was just 202. my sense of time's
[ __ ] i took some mushrooms the other
day and i went to the dodger game mm-hmm
so wild i feel like my brains my my time
is not bad it hasn't really come back in
line i guess not
because we were just at 102 and now
we're at what'd you say to what
30. we're done that's ridiculous
that's crazy we really we there's no way
we can do hour and a half episode
there's no way can't yeah it's
constantly realistic it's impossible
it's not realistic our [ __ ] face
times are 42 minutes isn't it
yeah it's not real man it's truly not
this can't happen
so guys an hour and a half turned into 2
30. here we go
uh there he is thank you very much i
only wrote a couple
bullet points i didn't want to talk
about too much i wanted to keep it
precise
that's all girls well you did you tell a
story too
but still damn 202 i started i put that
joint i want to be like 10 minutes ago
[ __ ] all right here we go thank you guys
so much for watching the ranty dope as
usual dope as ranty podcast ever
um i've had a kanye west stuck in song
stuck in my head since we started
talking about him
simultaneously playing while i was
telling the story and it was so
aggravating
trying to slow it down nobody's back
here while i told the story
[ __ ] okay here we go guys thank you so
much
again for listening to the dope as usual
podcast this is episode
26 5 5 episode 25th
i think pretty sure i think so guys uh i
made a promise
what'd i say by episode 100 yeah but
then you scaled it back to 52. to 52.
yeah i said the first episode i said by
episode 100 i want to be able to do a
pull-up
because i'm all out of shape and then
today we did a workout for like an hour
and a half and i [ __ ] died and almost
threw up
so i'm on the way there's progress
all right there's progress um
so by the end of the year we talked
about it in the manscape i mean
on the manscape we talked about it in
the on it earlier i'm trying to like not
be so fat
so that's pretty much the whole episode
of my day
today
that was the time to do it probably not
be so fat
guys thank you so much for uh watching
uh the giant just woke up justin how you
doing over there
he's just sitting there in the quiet
wearing orange um
puffiness just wasting weed smoke out
there you know
guys thank you so much for watching i
appreciate it from marty and i
what did we take away from this all
right
space jam was better left untouched
marty bought a [ __ ] house yup all
right
that was it don't let people rent your
car and then that's a rant with them
yes i have another story i don't even
want to talk about because i'm trying to
keep it precise i have a whole story
about that
where i was the guy that took the car
and jeebus rented it for me and someone
hit me first accident ever
[Music]
no insurance okay here we go
guys thank you so much for watching
before you get out of here if you're in
the chat if you've stuck around in the
chat this long
shout out to you thank you so much if
you're in the chat or if you're not in
the chat you're just watching do us a
favor
leave a comment who do you want to see
on the show
all right and not just like we people
weak people
who do you want to see world anybody it
doesn't have to be just
people that smoke weed you know or
people that just make weed videos you
know
i'm not saying that there's a couple
obvious ones that we got on the books
like yes but i want to see it in the
comments what do you guys
want to see because we're about to hire
that booking agent
that's going to make life so much easier
to book people and be able to get the
content oh that manager yeah i already
have that they were they're at
cma you know what i mean like oh they're
at this talent agency yeah i'll
talk to oh you want that athlete could
you get that athlete
yeah thanks booking agent
that's what we're going to do so this is
feasible now do us a favor
leave it in the comments who do you want
to see i know joey diaz i already got it
guys
joey diesel isn't york in jersey he's
not coming back anytime soon apparently
of course but it's not going to happen
anytime soon but
leave your suggestion all right i want
to see who you guys are watching
psych substance guy has been so much in
our stuff
i want to talk to that guy i want to
talk about drugs the most unmonetized
episode of all time
um guys thank you so much for watching
leave a comment uh who do you want to
see
if you just want to say hi drop a
comment leave a like like i said if you
can leave a like on the video it really
[ __ ] helps us thank you so much
before you leave
uh click the links below for all our
sponsors also our clips channel we just
hit
30 000. [ __ ] yeah thank you guys so much
for watching the clips channel
for marty and i new homeowner marty
i was waiting for it i was waiting for
it um guys thank you so much this is the
dope as usual podcast we're here to talk
about rant rant uh
rant drugs and rants and that's pretty
much about it pizza
and pizza homeownership homeownership
guys thank you so much for watching i am
thomas douglas uh
yola this is the dope as usual podcast
i'm high it's three in the morning have
a dope ass day
yo i need a clock
i need you know we need the comedian red
[Music]
lights
[Music]
perfect
[Music]